okay so
um I always say that every session is um
another chapter in my book
and and uh meeting in this room I can
now add this chapter has something very
unique is I get to not only
sit in the speaker's chair but I now can
see in this uh Infamous committee room
which is the finance committee room in
which uh
um so much happens occurs here so this
uh
but it's a big room isn't it
okay so
um we'll introduce Amelia garaldi from
the bank commissioner
and who will introduce the bill and the
uh so good morning for the record my
name is Amelia galderi I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire uh thank you for this
opportunity to provide information about
house bill 520.
um House Bill 520 was drafted at the
request of the New Hampshire banking
Department it started out as a technical
fix so
um about two years ago the legislature
um again at the request of the banking
Department working with industry
um made a change to how
um the interest rate for escrow accounts
is calculated so if you have a mortgage
and you have an escrow account the bank
or lending institution might be holding
an amount in escrow to pay for your more
your homeowners insurance your taxes Etc
um and the banking Department set the
interest rate on that account so the way
we used to set it is we would do this
kind of administratively burdensome
request of our chartered entities to
find out how much they're paying on
deposit accounts we would tally that all
up subtract one and that would be the
interest rate and because that was
burdensome on us to gather that
information burst them on the entities
that we regulated we worked with the
industry to change that and we attempted
to tie it to the FED funds index at the
time it was Zero it seemed like an easy
solution
less administrative burden good
um however we realized about six months
after that legislation was passed that
there was a cross-reference to that law
in our Mortgage Bankers and Brokers
statute yep so um and we had missed that
cross-reference so then even though the
banks were going forward with the new
calculation we still had to do the old
calculation for the Mortgage Bankers so
this bill as it's currently drafted was
meant to fix that and make them the same
um after we saw uh as this excuse me as
this uh progressed we um heard from the
bankers Association in particular but
that
um they because the FED fed funds the
has been the FED funds rate has been
increasing obviously as we're all aware
in the news
um and it was becoming somewhat
unmanageable even from a logistical
standpoint because it was always
changing they would have to go and back
date and it was a moving Target
basically
so we worked with the bankers to come up
with
um the amendment that's been circulated
that um effectively
one ties it to a new rate a new index
set by the FDIC on
um the national deposit rate for savings
accounts that's published by the FDIC so
we liked it because it was tied to an
index so we don't have to do the
administrative burden additionally
um this amendment
um
sets the rate every six months
so that takes away the moving Target
aspect of it and then we also requested
there be a floor in a ceiling so that
there's a minimum of 0.5 percent per
year that would be the minimum interest
rate and then there's a a cap of um I'm
sorry point zero five percent is the
floor 0.5 percent is the cap
um
for the interest rate that would be
applied to this the escrow accounts and
then additionally you'll notice there's
two sections because we caught at this
time there's the RSA 397a change which
mirrors the RSA 383b so those two are
effectively the same just one governs
mortgage companies and the other governs
Banks
so that's all that's the explanation for
what's in front of you and I'm happy to
answer any questions
um that you may have
okay representative magular I just have
one question and in the original bill
you were using the the overnight rate
and and now
um this rate this rate is likely to be
higher than the overnight rate isn't it
I don't think this rate I think is
currently lower than the credit funds
index okay thank you
[Music]
yes representative
my only question is
um this is not a and it's not stamped
unapproved amendments yeah this is yeah
this is from her so we would take this
over to legislative services and have a
full Amendment drawn up okay and it
replaces take it up in subcommittee okay
and then approve it all right but it
didn't it didn't make sense to discuss
the bill in its current uniform when
there was already a proposed amendment
okay thank you
any other questions oh representative
Herbert
uh you're going to use the FDIC
for which is updated every six months I
think you said it's updated more often
than that but we set two dates in time
to to tie it to so what I uh so
basically whatever
the fed the I'm sorry the rate is on
October 1st will be oh no I'm sorry July
so it gets published in July
October 1st it gets set and then it gets
published in January and April it gets
set based on the January rate okay so we
tied it to a point in time to make it
administratively easier to for the banks
to apply I get that I just was I was
just trying to figure out exactly what
that FDIC rate was being applied to and
it's you're uh is is your mortgages your
escrow account if you have one
they're all escrow accounts yeah
okay yep is there another any other uh
similar
I I I thought I heard too you did FDIC
but is there another index that you're
going to be
no this is
um but that will be no more if this
passes and the two rsas are the two
yes and and Banks both of which have the
thing in common that they might hold
they might require that their customers
have an escrow account and this governs
those escrow accounts thank you
thank you
this is for my own information because
I'm new at this but uh section 9
describes a person that is allowed to
collect this money or transmit this
money that has no licenses
and I'm trying to describe what kind of
a person is this it sounds like somebody
just walking off the street I think
you're on the next bill that's 522. I'm
so sorry we'll get rid of that one you
see okay once again you're going to see
representative Terry thank you uh just a
suggestion with respect to the document
that you provided for us it might be
helpful and if if you do this in the
future if you would just indicate it at
the top of the document stayed in one or
two sentences what the rationale is for
the changes that you're recommending and
so um because it's not there let me just
uh just for to for you to confirm to me
my understanding or to correct my
understand misunderstanding
the reason that you're going to be using
a less shall we say Dynamic rate and
move to a more static rate because
you're going to change this twice a year
is to make it administratively easier
for the banks in the mortgages companies
to to administer is just a yes yes okay
and and also I would add for for us as
the banking Department because to the
extent we receive a Consumer complaint
about an escrow account this makes it
much easier like a common complaint that
we get is my escrow account is not being
accounted for properly you know they
didn't pay taxes at the right time fill
in the blank
um so this will make it easier for us to
review as well follow
for the question thank you uh do do you
foresee that there be any adverse impact
upon uh borrowers consumers
no I don't I don't think so I mean
currently the FED fund rate is higher
than this contemplates but it's such a
small like there's not tons and tons of
money tied up at any given moment in an
escrow account there is some there's a
cushion but it's not a voluminous amount
so I think there would be minimal and
that rate has only been in effect for
like a year that that's been changing so
I think it's pretty de minimis okay
thank you
okay anybody else
oh representative
what do you say oh
thank you Mr chair
uh just trying to understand the last
sentence the uh
the 0.5 cap
um because maybe it's escrow that's it's
different than a savings account right
but we're used to near zero interest
rates but as the FED has been tightening
we're going to see interest rates on
savings accounts go up I'm looking at
bank rate it's between three and four
percent right now so if you just help me
understand the cap on the half a percent
sure so um an escrow account is both a
service
it's like some it's something that the
bank requires of most consumers but it
also assists the consumer so there's a
balance right
um the bank is interested in having the
Escrow because it helps protect the
collateral make sure that the taxes are
paid the consumer also benefits in some
ways because the bank is effectively
paying their taxes they're providing a
service so we felt like that cap was a a
reasonable compromise of those two
interests
will beg the interest how how high would
the interest rate to be higher than the
half percent
I'm sorry well so this based on right
now our interest rates are like four
percent right or five percent or yeah
for for a mortgage well so a mortgage is
different this is for the escrow
accounts so
um
there's a range I mean I think that New
Hampshire Charter Banks like which is
what we based it on in the past so for
13 years this rate has been zero because
we would take we would take in all the
the rates the interest rates chart uh
provided by Banks New Hampshire Charter
banks on their savings account
average them out and subtract one that's
how it used to be that's impact one
right yeah we subtract one so it was
it's been zero for the whole time I've
been at the banking Department
um because it's an escrow account not
but I remember the days when interest
rates were 16 so oh expense but while I
say that because for 13 years it's been
zero but I don't think for 13 maybe for
13 years now
I think there's been a range of
potential if you have money in a savings
account that you can get if you move it
around or whatever
um so I think this is the goal is to be
not burdensome and to strike that
balance because it's always a balance
between you know the consumer's interest
and the service provided by the bank so
this struck us that this was a good
balance based on that because this will
make it not zero like it's never going
to be zero again and it's been zero for
13 years so
um by setting that cap I mean that floor
so
like it's it's a compromise right
well yeah I guess so if I just think one
so that for discussion purposes that's
you can't but an assets are higher now
aren't they higher than that now it
depends on where you look
um
okay
but with with a CD you're trying to hide
the money up at that specific period of
time yeah so you can really compare it
it's because again they're providing
that service where they pay the taxes
and there's an admit there's a burden on
that there's assumption that the the
financial institution is not using that
cash for anything else other than
sitting in correct in in the Escrow
because it has to so most of them
require it to be a cushion of so many
months every six months you're paying
them so there's yeah death in taxes
twice a year that's a diet twice a year
yep
okay representative so in fact the money
that are in the escrow accounts cannot
be used for any other purposes they're
walled off that's a question for I would
because that really goes to the heart of
the question that the chairman is
Raising and and uh representative Ammon
that if if interest rates are two three
four five percent and you've set a
ceiling of 0.5 percent in the banks or
the mortgage lenders have an opportunity
to take that money while it's in escrow
and invest it then um they're making out
pretty well when interest rates are are
higher than 0.5 zero percent am I not
understanding this so I would defer to
the bankers Association because they and
I can't remember the date of the exact
numbers that they present me I would
need to do a little bit of research I
could probably get you that information
for the subcommittee work session to
give you the numbers on how much they
cost because
operating an escrow account costs the
bank money is my understanding and I
would have to go and look at those exact
numbers
I do understand what your question but
that's a huge yeah well it's huge only
that's a huge that's a huge uh
difference as with respect to whether or
not they can take all of the the
aggregate sums of All the Monies that
are in escrow and invest them on a
dynamic basis which I'm sure they're
very capable of doing
or not being able to do that and I mean
that so yes I would like to answer that
question because I think it's absolutely
let me buy correct they did some
analysis on the the costs versus the
benefit of the escrow account that I'm
sure that they can provide you and I'm
happy to go back and research your
question further
yeah so actually it kind of begs the
question of how people feel about the
escrow accounts because I know for
myself that
um my financial institution
doesn't require Escrow because I have
direct payment I have automatic payments
yeah it
in the terms of any any given mortgage
and that is set between
and the bank at the time they contract
um
it really depends on the a lot of
different factors the financial where
with all of the um applicant for the
loan the collateral all sorts of
calculations go into whether or not you
have an escrow so not you're correct not
everyone has an escrow account
um
okay sometimes it's mandatory some yeah
it's mandatory you say it's mandatory
we're talking about a mortgage talking
no I'm saying if I have a mortgage and
the conversation was about do uh you
know in terms of escrowing
taxes
I can wave that escrow on your taxes if
I give them direct you know automatic
payment right it's only if the bank
insists on an escrow that because they
want to make sure to pay you the
insurance and the taxes that this would
come into play right yeah it depends on
a lot of different factors um any given
person may or may not have an escrow
account if they have a mortgage it's
credit worthiness it's collateral
there's a lot of other there's a lot of
factors that go into weather loan to
value loan to value exactly
um all sorts of factors
okay
thank you very much thank you all right
the chair will call on Ryan Hale from
foreign
good morning chairman members of the
Commerce Committee for the record my
name is Ryan Hale I'm vice president
governor relations for New Hampshire
Bankers we represent 38 member banks
which employ roughly 6 000 employees
here in the state of New Hampshire
um I come before the committee uh not in
uh not a position on the underlying bill
but in support of the language that
commissioner galtiari has provided the
committee we really appreciate her and
her team's work on this to trying to
address our concerns back when this bill
passed two years ago
we we were supportive of it but after
the rollout there were some issues that
did come up
um as far as the implementation
especially as the FED continued to raise
interest rates and how it played with
banks core providers which are the back
end systems that
that transact um that that manage the
transactions uh for for the banks
um in the in the original language of
that bill that passed two years ago it
didn't specify exactly when uh that
um the interest rate had to be changed
so one would assume that it was
immediate when the FED raised the rate
and so the concern was uh what we heard
from some of our members was
um whether or not having to back date
and if you missed a day or uh missed it
by a day we were told by one member in
particular that they would have to then
manually go in and change the interest
rate on all 1800 of their escrow
accounts
um so it it did prove to be a very um uh
tedious process
um and with it changing now monthly
um this this language addresses that
concern uh by one tying it to the f DIC
savings account rate as well as giving
on ramp to when that has to be changed
I think the commissioner did a really
good job explaining the you know escrow
accounts there are high maintenance
accounts
um one of my Bankers shared that there's
two individuals within the bank that
manage these accounts for uh for the
bank they have to monitor uh all the
municipalities and changes to their
taxes and then issue checks um twice
twice a year in some cases as well as
pay the insurance it is a service to the
to the consumer
um and it it is uh it is a way to help
protect the interest also of the bank by
ensuring taxes are up to up to date so
at that point I will pause uh
representative Terry great question
about
um whether or not they can invest I I'm
not clear sure about the answer but I'm
happy to look into that and get you get
back to you so happy to take any further
questions from the committee
right representative Ammon
thank you for testifying Mr Hill
um thank you Mr chair
the current statute says that the
interest rate is posted on the
commissioner's website if
the commissioner shall post the rate on
the department's website and so I'm
so I guess I'm interested in what the
rate is right now that that would be
so it's if somewhere on this website it
says zero percent okay all right thank
you
and is it zero because of the minus one
but it's the minus one that that brought
right
so you have to look when you look at CD
accounts you got to look at New
Hampshire Banks not
that Capital One which he was looking at
which is three and a half percent five
percent
never used anyways right and their
demand savings I'm looking at the
department website no I understand that
but I was at the screen you looked at
before which which shows you higher
interest rates representative Herbert
um
it's a good thing you have Escrow
because I mean that's a
a hedge but uh
and I'm assuming most people do have
escrows on mortgages not everybody goes
in and pays cash for
a piece of property
um
what happens
and maybe 13 years is not more than
ironic uh
what happens when all of a sudden
um
a pant load of people go unemployed all
of a sudden because the Federal Reserve
created a recession
does that what's the impact on your
on the banks
uh in terms of these people now can't
pay
you know 13 years ago I think that was
the situation
definitely a common so I'm curious as to
what what do you do if the Federal
Reserve becomes successful and puts 20
so I'm not uh so uh I mean I think you
have a hedge but uh
now they're not going to be paying I I
just don't uh
what happened the last time this
happened uh we'll we'll work on figuring
yes representative Terry so the the uh
account so the rates that you're
surveying are State chartered Banks
yes and they're they're what we might
call demand savings accounts rates not
time deposits
what
what rates are you surveying on on what
kinds of accounts
yeah anybody so so you have to where we
have actually kind of sidetracked the
whole conversation when we brought in
CDs okay in CD interests what we have
heard from the bank commissioner is that
is probably not the right thing to do
because no one is in that position to
say is well do I want to have an escrow
or do I want to put the money in the CD
and earn a higher interest rate and then
tell the bank oh you can have you can
have that uh you can have that as
collateral to making sure I pay my taxes
on time okay so that conversation
doesn't exist the issue was that when
representative Ammon brought up it says
boy this is pretty low percent
you know why is it so low because in the
reality for banks evidently
it's really a burden to run these escrow
accounts because they got to hire
multiple employees they've got to
segment the money they got to write that
check you know twice a year they've got
to keep track of it and so they're
saying is how do you factor in the cost
that the bank has to maintain that
escrow account which you would not have
if you were saying oh that money's in my
CD and uh and I have my CD set up to
roll over every six months so that it
can make my payment for my property tax
bill
well that's that's a reasonable
supposition uh which you've just laid
out there
but but if but the way I was attempting
to frame the question is if if if past
books that we used to call past book
savings accounts are paying get to a
point where they're paying three percent
or four percent
and the escrow cap is 0.5
um and I had the option of whether or
not I wanted to have an escrow account
I'd be out of my mind financially
speaking to opt for an escrow account
when I could be making four percent on
his passbook but what we're getting at
here is the people who are mandated to
have Esco accounts and they they would
only be able to get 0.5 under this time
I believe it's a mortgage is a very
active Marketplace and so no one is
being mandated to have that escrow
account that would be the relationship
that you have with that bank that is
giving you that mortgage and if you
don't like it if you don't want to do
the escrow account you certainly are
free to go shop around to another bank
perhaps
practically speaking if your loan to
value is 98 or 99 I would challenge you
to find a lending institution that is
going to give you the option of not
having an escrow accountant and I speak
on personal experience okay okay so I
think we're getting a little off the
subject here so so you know I mean in
terms of do we want to clean this up
this is something that it seems a
reasonable compromise between the
banking Department trying to do this
efficiently and for the banks if you
don't want it if you want to leave the
Old Law you don't want to pass anything
but in terms of changing this half a
percent they have in my mind they have
made a case for why it's such a low
number and like I say is is as I know
for myself personally there are banks
that
there are banks that will waive it so
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um
first of all I'm not challenging the
amendment to the bill at all uh
I just have a question that I think is
closely related to it
um and I probably should have asked this
question of the previous
um uh person who testified so if you
can't answer it just say so
um but my question is uh how does this
requirement for how do these
requirements for interest apply when a
mortgage is purchased through the
so I I I believe that when it's sent off
to when it's sold off to the secondary
Market the bank still maintains the
retains the servicing rights it's my
understanding and they will they would
then I believe still pay the
um Insurance in taxes
um further inquiry further inquiry
um would you believe that from personal
experience I can tell you this is not
the case uh because my mortgage was
purchased by a bank in Florida and it
took me a considerable amount of time to
persuade them that in New Hampshire you
have to send the property taxes uh to
the city and not the county they kept
trying to send my property taxes uh to
the county which of course it was not
going to work in New Hampshire so the uh
taxes from the escrow account were
definitely being handled by the bank in
Florida that had bought out the mortgage
I'm sorry I misunderst I apologize but I
misunderstood your question the original
question
um as far as the secondary Market but I
believe I understand now what you're
saying is if it was sold to another out
of state bank
um they would be on that out of state
bank to
um
still take the escrow they require the
escrow and pay those
pay those taxes and insurance
for the question may inquire
sorry for the question uh
clarification yeah thank you
um and the requirement my original
question was how do these requirements
for interest
regarding interest apply to that out of
state bank
so it's again thank you for the question
um it's Meijer stated that
um these if it's a and I think the
commissioner may be able to help with
this but it's my understanding that um
out of State Banks if it's a mortgage in
New Hampshire that is required to pay
interest on escrow or I'm sorry that
takes an escrow
um they fall under the the requirement
to pay interest on that escrow if it's a
mortgage in New Hampshire and again I I
would ask to turn to the commissioner
yeah why don't you come up to the mic
yeah I can project pretty good yeah but
um but people at home can't hear you
okay okay
um so
apologize I couldn't quite hear from
back there everything that was being
said my understanding is is you had a
mortgage that was perhaps originated by
an entity that was a state Chartered
Bank it was sold to a Florida State
Chartered Bank
um I don't know if we've ever been
presented with that question before
um the RSA 383b applies to State
chartered Banks
um RSA 397a applies to Mortgage Bankers
mortgage brokers mortgage servicers that
are licensed with us if it was a
licensed entity no doubt yes if it was a
New Hampshire Bank no doubt yes I've
never been presented with this that
version of it I would have to do some
research I would also say that based on
the beginning of your question if you
had that much trouble with the entity
um you're welcome to file a complaint
with us and we would look into it
um that's that's that would be my advice
and then we could do a deeper dive into
it
um but off the top of my head I'm I'm
not sure this statute applies to State
chartered Banks thank you
okay
any more questions let's see none we
thank you all thank you does anybody
else would like to testify on House Bill
seeing none we'll close the public
hearing on 5 20. and send it to the
subcommittee
okay
next up uh 5 22 relative to money
transmitters
having me introducing the bill would be
a waste of time
especially when my committee members
time
I will introduce again our bank
commissioner and I'm sorry
good morning chairman my name is Seth
zaracki I'm the general counsel at the
basketball I can't remember it I don't
okay go ahead okay good good morning
chairman hunt members of the committee
um as I said my name is Seth seraki I've
served as general counsel at the banking
department since late spring of last
year
um thank you for the opportunity to
testify this morning regarding HB 522
this is an act relative to money
transmitters this bill was drafted uh by
the banking Department staff and we
sought sponsorship for this bill
uh HB 522 adds nine exemptions into New
Hampshire law from What's called the
model money transmission modernization
Act
so before getting into the details I
think it'd be helpful for me to give
some general background about money
transmitter regulation so what's a money
transmitter under current state law
money transmitters are companies that
receive money for transmission to
another location or sell or issue
payment instruments or stored value
persons who are who are engaged in the
non-exempt business of money
transmission
um
are subject to the banking Department's
jurisdiction and regulation
now money transmitters that may be
familiar to you would include Western
Union Moneygram PayPal that's just to
name a few of the Departments
approximately 175 licensees
many of these companies are nationwide
some are Global and and there are some
that are Regional uh the money
transmitter industry has shown
significant growth both in transmission
volume and in the variety of companies
that operate in this space
nationally operating companies have more
than doubled since 2015 and this is
largely driven by the Boom in what we
call fintech payment providers
so what does all this mean New
Hampshire's money transmitter law is due
for modernization when a company
operates in all 50 states you can
imagine the burden that it creates on
the company when they have to operate
under a patchwork of 50 different state
statute statutory regimes and variations
in the law
so bringing We Believe bringing
uniformities to the state laws in this
area is better for business it's better
for the regulators and it's ultimately
better for the consumers
so
um let me talk about the the the what I
refer to as the model money transmission
modernization act and this is where the
exemptions that are in our bill that's
where they come from so the model law
was developed by a joint working group
of State regulators and Industry experts
and it the the purpose of it is to set
Nationwide standards and requirements
for money transmission that are designed
to protect consumers and also enable
local innovation
um the standardization of exemptions
from money transmitter licensing will
promote consistency among the states
it'll make it easier for companies to
operate in multiple multiple States and
it will also make it uh easier for State
Regulators to leverage common practices
and Analysis the common standards will
eliminate unnecessary barriers barriers
to interstate commerce they will
eliminate inconsistency across the state
regulatory regimes and they will protect
New Hampshire's interests against the
threat of federal preemption in this
area so this this the idea is to keep
accountability for money transmitters at
the state level
um HB 522 this bill represents New
Hampshire's first step in implementing
the model law so this exemptions these
these exempt these additional exemptions
that we are seeking to add into our law
um are are a small our piece of the
model law or the although they're a
significant piece for industry and
Regulators
um and I think in next year the banking
Department intends to incorporate a much
broader swath of the model law
um and that will be next year we we
decided this year to focus on this piece
since it was important to the industry
and regulators and take undertake that
larger effort
um next year so
um HP 522 it specifically adds nine
separate exemptions to our money
transmitter law as a general matter
these new exemptions have two common
themes the first is they provide
exemptions and situations where
consumers upon sending their funds
they're no longer liable to the ultimate
intended recipient of the funds if those
funds are never received and then the
second piece is they provide exemptions
for entities that are regulated under
federal law you know one of the
exemptions is for the the USPS the U.S
the U.S Postal Service
um
so um I
in the bottom half of the handout I go
through uh there's there's a description
of each of the nine exemptions in some
detail so I I'd refer you to that for
the sort of the technical details of the
name exemptions
um and thank you for consideration of
this bill and I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have
but yes representative Herbert
um is this
I've been uh is this part of the
what's the organization and you you see
no that would be insurance would be coil
but it has a similar entity but so this
was developed by What's called the
conference of State Bank supervisors in
connection with with industry um so it's
the csbs I think we were we we spoke a
little bit about the csbs at one of the
uh the orientations session um with this
committee all right
different than the uniform law committee
the uniform lock or commission I can't
remember it's a committee or commission
they're the ones who developed the UCC
um
this is a different entity yep
right but it's more like coil you know
Council of insurance legislators or or
not Quail but uh ins and natural
associate of insurance commissioner NAIC
has the commissioner they do it at that
level they do I think that's correct I'm
not so familiar with the insurance
version right
okay yes representative oh thank you I
would say that I'm I'm breaking our
rules to letting you and I testify on
this bill like questions questions
exactly
um my question is this as I read but you
didn't testify that's why you're allowed
to
yeah as I'm reading this as I read the
bill
um it seemed to me that you could have
a
organization or a money transfer who is
exempt on this much of his business but
not exempt on that if that's the case to
the only report on the business they're
non-exempt from or does that make them
cover the exempt as well
uh yeah we will only regulate the
non-exempt portion of their business got
any other questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you is there
anybody else here would like to testify
on House Bill 522
see none it will close the public
hearing
so for the next bill anybody who wants
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
the house bill 595 and hear from our
foreign
good morning again for the record my
name is Amelia galderi I'm the bank
commissioner for this day of New
Hampshire I don't have anything super
prepared for this we're neutral on this
bill I just wanted to make myself
available to answer any questions you
may have this was drafted as a result I
believe of a study committee from last
year and this was the recommendation
from it I would point out
um that there is a slight issue with it
um they basically how this how this got
drafted I imagine is it got lifted out
of the bank commissioner's law and is
now being placed under the treasurer's
um State treasure yeah jurisdiction
however
um when they did that lift they left in
a reference to our costs so we have a
provision under current law that allows
us to charge the pool for banking
Department's costs in administering the
pool and that reference is on sorry I
should have had it right at my
fingertips but it's uh I think it's at
the end I was repealing a bunch of stuff
22.
on page one
yeah page one
um of the bill line 22. RSA 3 83 11. so
that would need to be changed because
that's our that's how we calculate our
per diem rate and I'd imagine the state
treasurer has a different way that she
would like her cost factored in okay um
but other than that that's just more of
a technical issue
um
and I'm happy to answer any questions
about the representative spear
I think I'm on the right bill this time
in reading this and I don't know the
history but in reading this I looked up
the account that it's in and it's a AAA
rated account so it's apparently managed
very well or at least very safely
and into the account goes money from all
kinds of municipalities and all sorts of
things that go into this uh oh I forgot
the name public deposit investment pool
the investment pool
and now what we're suggesting in this
bill is to put it under the state
as opposed to the banking
commission which is where it was managed
up to now and doing well
why are we doing that so generally
broadly speaking we testified to this
before the study committee so the
banking department is a regulatory
agency what we specialize in is going
into entities and examining them and
determining whether they're complying
with laws rules and safety and soundness
regulations we're not in like we're not
investment advisors although sometimes
our paths cross with them and I think
that um the better person to handle
these is the state treasurer because
that's more their area of expertise just
from a high level there's all sorts of
nitty-gritty other reasons that I could
give you but I think that in my mind is
the biggest highest level additionally
um there's an element where Banks stage
hard banks that are regulated by the
bank commissioner
um compete with the pool for these
deposits and so that creates a conflict
for me as the bank commissioner because
on one hand I have to sort of promote
this pool and then on the other hand
ensure the safety and soundness of these
entities that are competing with it
um it's just a little strange
um so I think it's a better fit under
the state treasurer right that as a
member of this of the over the study
I agree with that point exactly as I was
reading through this it seemed to me
that there had to be a little bit of
conflict of interest if banks
um but going back on this does this did
this is this taking place because a few
years ago they allowed the uh this
investment pool to go beyond uh fixed
income and so now they're looking for uh
maybe and it also said investment
advisor it didn't talk about multiple
advisors and I was a little concerned
about that that they couldn't hire you
know two or three or four different
investment advisors to handle different
sectors
part of your question I'm not quite sure
the pool was set up in 1991 I think that
given I was not around at that time but
given the um economic situation I think
there was concern that
um public deposits be have this option
available public municipalities and so
on and so forth the entities of the
deposit into the pool have this option
to safely deposit their funds I believe
that's in a nutshell the history
um and then there is just one investment
advisor that's how it's set up by the
statute we do an RFP every five or ten
years I can't quite remember whatever it
says in the statute to make sure that we
have
um a investment advisor who can handle
the fun follow the question main choir
do you know who the investment advisor
is at this point it's on pfm
um and they've been doing it pursuant to
the RFP they won the bid and they've
been managing it now for I think a long
time a long time yeah 10 years eight I
I've done
but I've been at the bank department for
10 years and it's been them basically
the whole time someone's here to
that it was cut water an entity called
cut water was the investment advisor
you've just different to follow up but
my question is I believe that that at
the time they took this over it was
basically under the what we'll call it
the prudent man rule and now I think
it's under the prudent investment uh
investor which allows these
municipalities to uh to invest more
aggressively so for example I'm a
trustee of the trust funds in in Jackson
and when I came on there that this is
all they had and they were earning 0.38
and so we moved to a uh took out the
money out of there and put it with an
investment advisor and now we're we're
investing in stocks and all that stuff
so I I thought that they had this com
this pool had the option to do that and
that's what I'm trying to find out
talking about and I'll have to think
about this a little bit more so
um bear with me I think that where a
town can invest their funds say use a
town as an example there's all sorts of
entities that might be depositing money
in the pool but where a town for example
can invest its funds is governed by
another statute altogether that's not
under my jurisdiction I think it's an
RSA 21. I want to say or seven it's a
low number RSA yeah
um local government okay
um and that that sets out a variety of
investment options for towns with their
funds so I think that's what you're
getting at not necessarily this
um but I could be misunderstanding I
apologize we will be taking this home in
subcommittee so you can pursue this yeah
and please like
talk about your question so I can be
sure to get you an answer thank you so
uh I have no more cards to say treasure
would you like to testify at all or and
it's it's an honor to have you here and
not going to crucify because my only um
my only comment was uh pointing out that
technical defect of the bill other than
that the state treasury doesn't take a
position we will simply follow the
direction of the legislature in this
case
um the only comment I will I will add to
that is that again we will be willing to
to administer uh the pool
um
if it comes to us great and do you know
what the correct RSA should be we don't
really have a specific methodology the
way that banking department does so we
will simply track our time and also we
will learn how much of our
Administration will take so um again
we'll simply just track our time and
perhaps charge the pool based on that
right so we're going to just delete
after the word uh per diem examination
charge delete established in the RSA
3831 colon eleven one right just
provided the requirement the cost of
personnel assistant through
the end of the sentence shall not apply
so from 9 22 to line 25.
okay so the whole sentence right right
okay
that will still allowed the private
Investments
well then I'll be happy to answer right
so at this moment I'm going to start I'm
gonna remain do you want the whole
sentence the cost of personnel assist in
the operation the pool shall be
determined in accordance with per diem
examination you want that delete also
you want the whole sentence deleted or
you want to leave just that per diem
that will work uh Miss chairman just
because we do not have that specific
methodology
um again we will have to figure it out
really a methodology for us but we will
probably start tracking our time so
we're going to do a subcommittee so it'd
be great if you guys spend a little time
and if you want to create something for
us that would be helpful absolutely
happy to do that great thank you
I'm sorry I forgot your name but but
you're you're all set okay all right so
I have no other cards
and no one wants to speak we will close
let's see
to Marvel how I do that huh
okay
all right we'll open up the public
hearing on House Bill 648 and hear from
the prime sponsor representative Gerhart
you did fill out a pink card right I see
you have a pink card in your hand
okay you'll get it to me afterwards
good morning good morning thank you
Bill my name is Jason gerhardt I
Bill 648
establishing a state-owned bank sounds
very intensive but it's really not that
complicated the state of North Dakota
has had a state-owned bank since 1919.
it was in regards to a essentially a
farmer's revolt against the powers that
ought not be back East that controlled
the banking sector so they said hold on
we can just do this ourselves
they take all tax revenue by law put it
into the state-owned bank
and then they're able to leverage it
which you only need 10 of you know Banks
Reserves
so they can loan out essentially nine
times what they have in their vaults to
the state for state infrastructure now
North Dakota has extended their their
Banks purview a little bit they've
actually got into dealing with student
loans and some other things that
actually benefit the people of the state
so it's one of those things where
obviously it can be tailored to the
desires of the state and the people's
needs so it's not just you know
this structure that can't be altered
I have
given you a packet of paper which the
first two pages is what I want to
discuss first in that this bill well the
state-owned bank does not does not
compete with local banks it is actually
there to support them to provide
liquidity to them for instance look at
the chart on page two
North Dakota
has
like way more Banks per 100 000 people
they have nearly 12 Banks where the U.S
average is two
so obviously you've been doing something
writing on the first page the second
paragraph
the small state of North Dakota has more
Community Banks than Hawaii Maine and
New Hampshire combined these states
together have more than six times as
many residents as North Dakota and this
is from a
I have it here it's a Northeast Midwest
public policy Institute paper just
detailing the the applicability of
public Banks to that sector of the
country
now in the facts page this is from the
public banking Institute which is
uh run by a woman named Ellen Brown
she's an attorney actually out in
California but she's been pushing this
public banking concept for a long time
and the information they have on the
website is amazing I was actually just
in touch with them late into the hours
last night getting everything squared
away
and she submitted to you guys a two-page
written testimony that was emailed to
so I'll just kind of talk a little bit
about that but I won't detail it
so
let's okay let me go this route
does the Bank of North Dakota actually
make any money for the state that's kind
of critical to this whole thing it's not
according to the Wall Street Journal
this is a 2014 article
the Bank of North Dakota is more
profitable even in Goldman Sachs and
JPMorgan Chase perch's latest annual
report in 2021
the Bank of North Dakota had a return of
investment of 15 10 billion in assets
and an s p rating of a plus stable that
same year JPMorgan Chase had an Roi of
eight percent
it's pretty impressive when you look at
it and what I like the most about the
concept is that it's completely publicly
accessible we know where all the money
is going and it stays within the state
so we're not dealing with Bank of
America whatever any of these major Mega
Banks where they're taking the money and
just shipping it out all the money is
staying here four things we need
so when you build a bridge or any kind
of public infrastructure half the cost
of that project goes to interest
payments and especially now that if
their interest rates are going up
why would we spend double the amount of
money we need to build a bridge when we
can just do it ourselves with our own
money
it just I don't see the rationale and
especially
if she addresses this in her
her
testimony
so what about risk-free rights the
largest Wall Street Banks where most
States currently Bank are facing massive
hidden risks in the forms of trillions
of dollars in derivative Holdings JP
Morgan Chase alone has 55 trillion in
derivatives some Financial commentators
are pointing to these speculative bets
is the Black Swan that could take down
she doesn't it's in here somewhere but I
don't know where it is and I want to
waste your time but also we have the
issue of bail-ins so we're all familiar
with bailouts and the government comes
and gives Banks a bunch of money that
just disappears but in Cyprus and
elsewhere they actually took depositors
money to cover their losses that's what
they call a bail-in so I
I see no reason why we should put the
people of New Hampshire at risk for that
if our state tax money is going to these
Banks and all of a sudden they say hey
guess what guys we're broke we are all
in this together I don't want to be in
it together with them
I think we should just go our own way
and I mean
it's it's a it's an American
tradition I mean the bankers I mean the
farmers out in North Dakota said we're
done and I just I don't know I just find
that so amazing so
the transparency is obvious so
politicians can't take this over
I would really like to answer some of
your questions instead of just going on
your first
thank you thank you for taking my
question over here okay
um my question is my understanding is
North Dakota is the only state bank in
the country
so this thing has been so wildly
successful why is why are they the only
one doing this
one answer one one word answer lobbyists
so there was actually a white paper put
out I believe it was I was trying to
look for it last night but I couldn't
it's out there somewhere but
I forget what it is the Rockefeller
funded something this actually has
Rockefeller right in it but they put out
a white paper in 2017 or so saying that
you know New Hampshire doesn't need this
bank and blah blah blah the established
Banks
they would stand to lose a lot
in the way of fees so another thing
that's interesting and they got caught
red-handed I mean the mega banks are
pretty they're felons on a whole nother
level but
literally they've they just paid the
fines and write them off on their taxes
and keep it moving
but there was a scandal where they were
manipulating the the interest rates paid
to town so if I want to build a bridge I
get a 50 million loan to build it or
School let's say
you don't spend all that money at once
so you slowly take out of that and the
money that's remaining in that account
they're supposed to pay you interest on
which is competitive market rate well
they were playing games with their other
friends and keeping the rate
artificially low that was a big Scandal
I want us don't quote me on the exact
name of it but if you want I will submit
testimony as regards to that Rolling
Stone Matt taby actually did an article
on it it was he's a really good writer
and that was very well done but
follow-up for the question may inquire
other organizations
um
banking every the banking Department who
else has been involved in putting this
bill together and who have you consulted
who would be impacted
not many so getting elected I didn't
realize the timeline was so tight in
submitting bills so I'm not gonna lie I
kind of was but I wanted to get this in
because I campaigned on this I literally
went door to door in Franklin or
Northfield and people are excited about
this I mean why would you want to spend
double on a public infrastructure
project it doesn't make any sense
there's no justification for it we're
going to go through an institution that
has less transparency could eventually
steal your money and besides that I mean
they're engaged in a whole bunch of
shady stuff anyway at least we'll know
now that money is somewhere safe and
stays in New Hampshire that's the
critical thing to this as far as I'm
concerned keeping the money here it's
our money
representative Spears next
I glanced through the papers that you
gave and I found most of those online
New Hampshire collects its taxes and its
fees
keeps
the generate what it does with that
money is controlled oftentimes very
locally at municipalities like property
taxes
state taxes are used for things within
the state
no one consults anybody outside of the
state
we don't give our money to people to
control it as they did when new when
North Dakota started their problem
we don't do that here it's not like we
go and ask a bank in New York are we
allowed to build a bridge we don't
everything is done locally here
in order to do this we would have to
take our money from the taxes and
instead of the state treasurer and
everybody else who we have
constituted to take care of that money
for us with a triple threat a triple A
rating
we're going to ask a new bank to take
that money instead is that what we're
asking them to do
start up just a whole nother new bank
to make up for all the laws and all the
control we have on what happens to our
money now
is that what you're asking for
no I would say that the treasurer is
intimately involved with the the
Runnings of this bank this is not some
kind of
shade ball operation Opera it's so Bank
of North Dakota has one
building that's it there's no branches
so it doesn't compete this I know that
wasn't your question but
It's contained within that one aspect
and what I would say is when we're
taking our taxes and we're putting it
into any account any municipality
whatever it may be that let's say it's a
million dollars that million dollars
just sits there now yes we're getting
interest whatever one percent but with
the magic of fractional instead of
banking you can multiply that in loans
essentially 10 times so if I have a
Million Dollars in My Vault I can loan
up to nine times I only need ten percent
of that sitting in the vault if this
makes any sense I know it doesn't really
make sense and it really shouldn't be
this way but this is the magic of
fractional Reserve Banking and hence our
problems since the Federal Reserve but
so you're actually able to multiply that
money and then use it for loans and
you're loaning it to to entities that
aren't going to go out of business if we
build a bridge in Concord is Concord
going to disappear tomorrow are they
going to run off with the money and go
to the Bahamas it's one of those kind of
things where these are these are
investments that are extremely stable
and I just want to add unrelated but
related
that I'm on e-dna and we've been dealing
with a lot of pension issues and there's
actually people throughout the country
that are looking into taking
the the pension money that's just
sitting there I mean you know it's
making six and a half percent or
whatever their their figures are their
targets but if we could take that money
and then multiply it
nine times you're there's no loss if
they're all secure loans and you don't
have to mult you don't have to leverage
it to the max I'm just saying that's one
idea one Theory and this there's other
bills inside the states
why would those loans be any more secure
than whatever the banks are doing now
people I
I got you I got you so I mean um the
issue is fees generally
so she discusses it here here we go
all right according to Moody's Municipal
Bond default rate between 1970 2012 was
0.012 virtually Zero versus 3.6 for
corporate bonds okay so they're very
safe
yet a costly and involved certification
process is required to qualify municipal
bonds and bond Underwriters get the fees
these big out-of-state banks have caught
have been caught in collusion which I
mentioned earlier bid rigging and bad
swap advice paying over 2 billion in
fines and fees since 2000.
to avoid those fees some local
governments have been borrowing directly
from the banks according to Moody's
twenty percent of new Municipal
borrowings are direct bank loans
advantages include lower rates fuel
regulatory hurdles and lower transaction
costs including avoiding fees for rating
agents credit enhancements Bond trustees
and their attorneys
there's also no need for voter approval
new money is created as credit for the
local economy and rather than paying
interest for 30 years on a jumbo Bond
municipality can just draw on its credit
line with the bank as needed does that
kind of make sense
look I'm not gonna lie I'm a car no I'm
not gonna lie I'm a carpenter so this
banking stuff's a little bit new but
just to me it's very basic and I I just
love the fact that a bunch of farmers
said hold on we're done and I'm not
saying that this bill that I submitted
is perfect it most likely can use some
work and there's actually some
suggestions that we were discussing
about it
but I think the basic concept is solid
so
okay we have a lot of questions next up
is representative Gibbs
and thank you sir thank you
you've given us Pages 21 and 22 of a
document can you tell us what that yes
what that document is and where we can
find the rest of it I will submit it to
you I was worried about setting you
three million Pages before the hearing
go oh and everybody just taken call in
sick today it's the Northeast Midwest
Institute white people white paper
public banking in the Northeast and
midwest states September of 2019. I will
submit it to the now if you just submit
the link send the whole thing you know
email let me just want the whole report
yeah as PDF yeah done yeah it doesn't no
printing paper unless they print it on
their own well no it's 90 pages I was
gonna print it I was going to send you
the link but I'll send a PDF if you want
no problem we've seen big big stuff okay
uh representative thank you um obviously
this is going to take some Capital
um and that's my question how much
Capital do you think it's going to be
required to get it started and what
sources out of in New Hampshire or do
you think it'll come from
there's a paragraph that addresses that
exact issue so but so what about Capital
the amount required and where to get it
depend on state regulations and what you
want the bank to do that's the critical
thing we have to figure out what we want
this bank to do it's scope but we've
seen figures ranging from 10 million to
35 million depending on the state
sources could include a budget
appropriation bond issue or debt for
Equity swaps trading Securities for
you do realize a bond issue is illegal
under the banking Department's
collateral requirement I mean a cash
value in other words it has to be real
money to be invested in a bank in New
Hampshire
you would be violating New Hampshire
State Bank regulation okay I'll have to
work on that then okay that could be a
problem
representative Terry thank you
uh you've given us a lot yes and a lot
to think about uh I find this to be a
fascinating
proposal
the states are are Laboratories for
Innovation that's one of the beauties of
our federal system
I'm
you're new you've just presented this uh
for the first time I'm wondering if you
would be at all amenable to uh a
suggestion of a study committee or a
study commission so that uh more
broadly representative
input could be provided to this
committee
definitely I yes I think the more people
we can get involved especially the state
agencies and try to figure out what we
want this bank to do what it's you know
indeed thank you thank you okay
representative Burroughs thank you I
just needed a clarification because
um it's you know in the beginning of the
bill it said that this is
um
narrowly focus on public funds but yeah
and on page two it said that the board
advisory committee is going to actively
enlist the help of private interest
price and encourage the use of the bang
so could you explain that well I would
say that ref that's more related to the
first page when we're talking about how
North Dakota has the most banks per
capita this bank is designed to support
the smaller Banks who are really being
squeezed out
that's the main goal as far as I'm
concerned because smaller banks are more
intimately involved with their their
corresponding neighborhoods and whatever
you want to call it
so
if we have many smaller Banks it
provides more competition lower rates
and better service for the individual
communities involved instead of just
having Mega bank that everybody's got to
travel to it does that make any sense am
I answering the question follow up yeah
I'm still confused how are you
separating public and private funds if
you're getting you know how are the let
me rephrase it how are these Community
Banks involved if the if their State
Bank is basically just overseeing public
funds
so instead of having to go to
the Federal Reserve essentially for a
line of credit they would go to the
State Bank
that's my point does that make any sense
so they're not dealing with
the major
okay well I think we'll clarify that as
well yes okay I'm probably answering it
wrong so I'm not I apologize
thank you Mr chair
um some laptop is useful for doing the
research would you believe this is the
sixth time this bill has come before
this committee it's a bipartisan issue
the last time it was submitted in 2019
it was sponsored by representative
Marple
and representative Horrigan so that's a
bipartisan bill
um
so we have some history to go through uh
would you believe to uh see why it
didn't pass this committee uh five other
times
yes that would be more than welcome and
I would just say it most likely has to
do with the powers that ought not be
trying to put the squash on it I think
this is a this is a very
very big deal
not not me unless I but the bill the
idea of just having a public bank for
instance Tennessee right now there's a
senator nicely that's pushing their bank
but they're actually combining it with a
gold depository
and I think that's an interesting twist
that might have some interest in the
state but just the idea of it's all
about keeping our wealth here
I don't know if that I'm getting that
message across but yes
yeah
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um I need to request some clarification
earlier it sounded as if
um
the purpose of this bill and the purpose
of establishing a state bank was to
provide a better means of funding public
projects
um but
um
you also just said that the main goal
was to
support smaller Banks could you clarify
a little bit about uh the goals of this
proposal well the smaller Banks could
provide
money for public infrastructure projects
it's all really how we format the bank
and what the authority like if if the
smaller bank has the ability to provide
the loan at a competitive rate
then I think we should go that route
instead of going directly to the
state-owned bank it's just there this
they're the Clearinghouse that's that's
basically what I'm trying to get across
great so uh Before I Let You Go
um you you do know that like for student
loans we have nifa we have that set up
and we have the Bia for business loans
so that that all those things that that
bank does we actually have here in New
Hampshire but we just have it structured
differently than having it through their
one statement you do know that right
well I would say are they able to
leverage it though
potentially nine to one uh
20 that they have
okay so I'm not sure where you're going
with that but let me ask you another
question that is is uh you kept talking
about Banks
um so New Hampshire is very lucky to
have the very first credit union which
is a non-profit
Community oriented yep
you didn't mention
[Music]
them Credit Unions at all when you're
talking about your comparison to other
states with banks
and I would say is that we have a very
Lively Credit Union uh uh Association
here in New Hampshire that uh would be
doing those Community loans and be
focused on the communities and taking
care of the communities that much which
you were hoping this tank State Bank
would be and the last thing I'll leave
you with because we have had this bill
before and I have been around
for a fair amount of time that the
number one issue
was that North Dakota was able to start
their bank because at the time they had
a huge windfall tax on resources that
were being mined out of the state
and the what they were trying to do is
what should we do with this money
well how about let's make sure the
farmers can borrow it that's make sure
the farmers can tap into it and that's
why they created that State Bank because
they had a windfall unless we can figure
out how we can get more people to buy
granite
I'm not sure we have any resource here
that somebody wants to come and Quarry
and give the state a huge windfall
appreciate that as far as credit unions
go the problem is they can't multiply
their money as Banks can
so if they have a hundred dollars in
their vault they can't now loan out nine
times that amount they don't have the
reserve requirements aren't 10 like they
are for commercial Banks that's the
difference does that make any sense so
we have we have requirements on you know
under our banking statutes that the
credit union has to comply with just
like any Bank requires okay so when you
talk about their resources the money and
and the last time I saw this bill not
marples bill I don't remember that one
but
representative Valley Frazier put it was
was the idea of that if you could take
the state's checking account and just
put it over there but you can't call
that Reserves
because that's a moving account that
money is going in and out reserves is
sunk you know Capital that's in an
institution
that's what you need to find is you need
to find a hundred million dollars that
you can give to this institution
and that is their asset then they can
loan based on the nine the formula that
you're talking about
I would I would love to work on that as
Mr representative Terry mentioned I
would I think we can find it I think
it's it's desirable enough and it's it's
profitable enough to make it worth the
effort fair enough
representative Herbert has another
question
would you believe
there's actually a book
everybody can read about public Banking
and it goes beyond just North Dakota
so and around the world there are a lot
of public Banks there there's common as
dirt so it's not a it's not a
some sort of strange uh you know balloon
in this guy
they're all over the place we the United
States doesn't have but one
and uh I've read the book and I've
gone through it but brown brown solution
yeah public Bank Solutions but but the
point is it's just a bank
and it has does banking functions know
more differently than
the private banking system except that
there's a couple of differences and one
is the money does stay in the state
and number two the priorities on where
that money goes goes into Community
Banks and and the result of that has
been a very strong robust bank one of
the best in the country
uh and it came 2019 did that happen
that's a that's an interesting year was
that suffrage okay anyway would you
believe the question I think he said no
would you believe that he did say that
he's not as complicated as some people
here obviously think and uh fair enough
it's on if I'm if I may just briefly
it's unfortunate that banking has been
given this shroud of incomprehensibility
to anybody that isn't you know initiated
in the art
money
as well as she wrote in the summer books
but money is public infrastructure as
far as I'm concerned the currency we all
need it as it's as important as the
roads and it truly is a means of
transportation between transactions and
I just I don't see why we've
essentially gone against the
Constitution given this power to these
private corporations private Banks
including the Federal Reserve so thank
you so I would hope this committee since
the original name of this committee was
banks that I hope we aren't too shrouded
in in the secrecy
representative Terry Mr chairman uh
thank you and for the benefit of the uh
tens of thousands who are watching live
on YouTube and would not uh be able to
uh gain this information
um otherwise because I would have
mentioned it to you during the break uh
your question with respect to credit
unions is actually addressed in the
document that the sponsor has provided
us on an unnumbered page which I think
once again underscores uh how important
it is that we move to the subcommittee a
level consideration and perhaps think
about a study committee or a study
Commission because here in New Hampshire
we don't shoot things down just because
they've never been done before thank you
that's a would you believe it's a
Chinese balloon and representative
spirit
after it's off the coast
I don't think the issue is the fact that
it's a bank I don't think that's the
issue at all setting up a bank is known
people do it all the time it's done all
over the place this is another bank and
in fact the chairman of this bank has
said if you want to set up a public Bank
you better hire Bankers because no one
else is going to do it right fine
the question I have is
we have very many established
um
organizations or departments within this
state that do so many of the things
you're talking about
and what you're suggesting is tear them
all apart and start all over again and
do it this other way that's a very huge
burden
if I
would you believe no
would you believe me no I would say that
this Bank well first off the bill is in
your hands
you weak you can decide to have this
Bank do as little or as much as you want
in consultation with I'd say interested
parties which is important
but I once you start looking at the nuts
and bolts of this I think your opinion
will change
it's it's just very
just look into it a little bit I'm just
saying I think it has a lot of legs it
has a lot it has legs it can do a lot of
thank you thank you thank you okay so uh
since it is banking day we have the bank
commissioner one more time
foreign
Todd Wells
nice to see you Todd
good morning again for the record my
name is Amelia galderi I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire with me is Chief Bank examiner
Todd Wells uh the banking thank you for
this opportunity to provide information
on this bill the banking department has
no position on the bill uh the
underlying politics of whether or not to
form a State Bank however we are here to
answer any questions you might have and
additionally
um
point out some issues with the bill the
way it's drafted and perhaps some
general questions that you would need to
think about if you wanted to do this I
will say that forming a bank is a
complicated and expensive process I
understand that transparency is
important and I do value that but um it
is a there are things to think about if
you want to do this
um so just some general data on public
Banks it's probably addressed in the
materials that you've already been given
but in the last 100 years or so in the
United States and Associated territories
there have been about 29 public Banks
chartered out of the 29 that have been
chartered in the last hundred years only
two remain one is the Bank of North
Dakota I apologize in advance if I say
South Dakota I've been saying South
Dakota all day it is North Dakota just
for the record there are credit card
people South Dakota maybe I feel like
yeah I don't I don't quite know why
where my brain is it is North Dakota
and the other remaining
America some since the territorial Bank
of American Samoa
those two banks have something in common
about how they were formed both of them
were formed with a specific purpose to
address a need so my understanding is
that in America some American Samoa
there is not sufficient access no banks
are there so they need a bank to provide
services to the people who live there
basically in summary I I think a lot of
it has been said about the North Dakota
Bank but my understanding it's sort of a
similar scenario there was like a unique
circumstance that was very specific to
North Dakota that led to its formation
um so just as a data point the other 27
banks that have been formed in the last
hundred years have all been closed due
to either regulatory order
um Financial failure or the state just
chose to go in a different direction so
that's kind of the high level history on
public Banks
um
a big question that needs to be answered
um well there's a number of big
questions but the two big questions I'd
say that need to be answered if you're
thinking about forming a public bank is
number one will it be subject to the
banking Department's regulation and
related to that if it is
um it would require FDIC insurance and
have to comply with the fdic's capital
rules
right now if you want to form a private
bank a plain vanilla one nothing too
complicated I'd say this would probably
be in the complicated bucket but if you
want to form a plain one you're a
private entity wanting to do that you
need like some seed money you need
probably
five million of seed money three up to
up to five million of seed money
um just to form it just to make the
plans get it operational and then to
comply with the capital requirements of
the FDIC you'd need about 20 to 30
million dollars
um just to get the doors open and FDIC
insurance if that's the route you want
to go
um then after it's formed there's what
we call a capital burn so the bank
doesn't make money for a while because
it's getting up and running it's hiring
all the people it's getting the deposits
in it's doing all that stuff so you
would have a number of years before this
bank would be profitable
comparing it to a private bank
um
so those are kind of the big picture
things
um some other issues kind of
tangentially related to that if it's
going to be regulated by the New
Hampshire banking Department first off
this bill would need to change to say
that very clearly we would be going in
and doing examinations we would be
charging the entity our examinations our
reports of examinations are confidential
because
um
we want to prevent basically a run on a
bank like you want to keep that
information is for the bank to come into
compliance with laws and rules and those
are that's the kind of the policy
reasons behind why reports of
examination are confidential their
private entities performing private
services
so that's like another wrinkle that you
would want to think about if this is the
route you want to go
another additional thing that I would
note is banks that are formed in New
Hampshire have to be either a
corporation or an LLC under our law so
you would need to pick one of those
buckets to make it kind of a corporate
entity
um
I'm just going to list off some other
things to think about too
um
first this the way this bill is set up
the bank commissioner would be an
ex-officio member of the bank so
I can't run the bank and examine the
bank that's a conflict additionally
um
if the bank is going to provide the
services that have been enumerated
um it would be the same kind of conflict
as the public deposit investment pool
that we spoke about earlier
I would be examined like basically I
would be running a bank that competes
with the other banks that I regulate so
that conflict would exist again
um
let's see there's definitions that
conflict with our statutes
um I would also say that there would be
a similar problem with there seems to be
an advisory committee that would consist
of Private Bank Bankers so they would
also have that conflict they'd be tasked
with like running a bank that competes
with them
um so these are just all things that you
need to think about pretty carefully
before you do this
um
I could go on and on um I think that's I
I Pro I don't want to I don't want to
like have you guys all like I'm happy to
discuss it and provide any information
you may need
um but it is a complicated process you
need to think about conflicts of
interest you need to think about what
business the bank is going to do I agree
with some of the earlier testimony that
a lot of these services are already
provided by entities like the public
deposit investment pool like you know
any of the entities that were already
listed so these are all things you need
to think about
um
and also I think this is my fourth time
hearing about a public bank before the
house Commerce Committee and I believe
not the last time but the time before
that there was an interim study done
pretty extensively we dove into it a lot
and I think they issued a report
um I think representative Frazier was
the uh sponsor yeah so I think if if
you're looking for that data you can go
and review that um report you know how
that can be accessed I believe through
the website they redid the website so
I'll make sure we get that for
okay but are you going to ask a question
is this yeah sure I can ask one I can
ask 50. but but the first one I would
say the banks that failed
do you know when that happened I don't
have a timeline for all of them but I
believe it's been studied in various
reports so I'm happy to go and get that
information for you would you believe I
I would think the majority of them
happen during the Great Depression when
a lot of banks went under
the other thing is uh we
um
would you believe that a lot of what you
just said about changing uh being having
conflicts of interest and whatnot
this isn't actually a really new bank it
it would be formed in such a way as to
do the least amount of
uh changes in the government you would
still be the banking commissioner is
this a question
would you believe oh it's changing well
I mean okay I'll stop you're you're on
the Banking Committee yeah so it wasn't
you can express all your feelings off my
book I know thank you for your question
all right everybody else had any other
questions
thank you very much thank you I have one
more card left Ryan Hale from the evil
lobbyist organization called the New
well I'll be sure because I think the
commissioner did a great job uh
highlighting some of the uh some of the
concerns that we share
um with this bill but uh uh chairman uh
honorable members of the House Commerce
consumer affairs committee for the
record my name is Ryan Hale again vice
president of government relations for
the New Hampshire Bankers Association we
represent 38 member banks employing
roughly 6 000 people
um I'm here today to testify in strong
opposition to house bills 648 as drafted
um and previously mentioned uh this Bank
directs a state to establish a state-run
bank to take uh public deposits and make
loans to public entities not private
individuals or legal entities
um we heard some uh arguments on why uh
this institution uh is needed but the
cost potential problems we see are
numerous in particular we see this
legislation raises several questions
which uh we think Warren's particular
attention for example
is this is there a need for a public
State Bank as already mentioned there's
many public quasi-government lending
agencies within the state we have the
New Hampshire business Finance Authority
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
we have the public deposit investment
pool all provide services to State and
local municipalities
um as mentioned also this is the sixth
time in the past 15 years this proposal
has come up I believe this this proposal
is nearly identical to the 2019 proposal
which I think failed
um uh and committee or received an
experience to legislate almost I believe
almost if not unanimous recommendation
out of this committee there is also
um as part of the Cannabis legalization
Bill last year there was a State Bank
proposal that was put in there
um for to establish a State Bank of
financial services were not made
available to the state in ways and means
they quickly removed that provision
um after we were we articulated the
concerns of establishing a State Bank
um the commissioner mentioned uh between
2000 or 1917 2017 there were 29 public
Banks only two exist today North Dakota
as well as American small Bank
um again for the reason at the time it
was not sufficient banking services
uh well the other question we have is
will the public funds be insured uh this
bill is unclear uh whether or not these
funds will be insured uh State Charter
banks in New Hampshire required to have
FDIC Insurance question comes about is
what happens if this Bank fails who's
responsible
um it's our understanding most likely
could it would be the taxpayers that
would be responsible for failure of that
bank
uh the commissioner did a good job I
think highlighting
um the conflicts of interest
um one additional is unclear as as the
Department's funded by its regulated
entities
um it's unclear would these regulated
entities subsidize the cost of the
department
um overseeing the State Bank
um
that would need to be addressed
and then also how much will the bank
cost to operate
um it's tremendously expensive uh the
question about Capital was raised
um this bill and there wasn't a fiscal
note however if you look back I believe
in the 2019 proposal I believe again is
nearly identical to this bill
um I believe the treasurer's analysis at
the time was about 50 million dollars in
capital uh for that bank
additionally uh the sponsor mentioned
the Nelson a Rockefeller Center at
Dartmouth they analyzed the 2000 I think
16 State Bank and it concluded it would
need as much as 63 million in capital to
meet the minimum Capital requirements at
that time
Additionally the California state
treasurer and this is very narrowly
focused but they commissioned a study
back in 2018 they used level 4 Ventures
uh to look at establishing a state bank
for cannabis and again very narrow but
in the end
and it speaks to some of the points the
commissioner made uh just under a
billion dollars would be needed in
capital again different different
economic environment however
um to just illustrate that additionally
the bank would lose money for what they
said was about 12 years and wouldn't see
net dividends for 25 to 30 years after
the bank opens its doors
so in closing uh actually before or it
closed just a couple other
points I'd like to make the sponsor had
mentioned that this wouldn't compete
with st with the banks in the state
um I would argue that our State Banks as
well as National Banks uh have Public
Public Accounts public deposit Municipal
deposit accounts and do bank with the
state as well as municipalities
as far as money leaving the state there
was a bill a couple years ago that
opened the door to out-of-state
chartered Banks coming into the state to
take Municipal deposits and one of the
things we were concerned with was the
money leaving the state so we put a
lending test in we we worked with the
sponsor to include a lending test
requiring that that the bank these out
of state Charter Banks must lend equal
to the amount of deposits they take to
ensure the money is invested back in New
Hampshire and I think the last thing is
when a bank is a or bank takes Municipal
State funds public funds they have a
fiduciary responsibility to ensure
um you know to to the to the state to
the municipality so in closing for all
the reasons I listed uh we're in strong
opposition to House Bill 648
um it's it's uh
uh you know it's expensive it's risky
and I would respectfully ask the
committee to do as this committee has
done in the past and move in expedient
to legislative I'm happy to take any
questions the committee may have and I
do have written testimony that I will
hand out clerk appreciates that yes
sorry I forgot to mention that at the
beginning but I do ever in testimony
okay
any questions oh my God representative
and you really have a question this time
do you and I don't know if you know the
answer to this question but uh
there is a a lot of deposits of
State monies are City monies Municipal
monies here and there and everywhere and
they're scattered in
I was just wondering maybe the
commissioner can answer this is what is
the largest single deposit of public
money
uh thank you for the question
um I do not know the answer to uh the
but
okay
anybody else we're all set
thank you very much thank you I have no
more cards
anybody else want to testify seeing none
we close the public hearing on House
Bill 648 and we'll send it to the
yet
eventually
okay
yes
in question
um the uh subcommittee on legalization
of cannabis it looks like that's a
special subcommittee with six specific
people
you think
so it's it that's a special subcommittee
right but I'm I'm on there and I'm not
on the liquor committee
right but I'm on this I'm on this
special committee
here
everybody
foreign
women
Kentucky
um
experience
foreign
okay
so this um past year I was on two study
committees the first one we did this
morning the public deposit investment
pool
and then I'm also appointed to the his
history committee
and um and David Welch who used to be on
but he didn't run so I'm now
I'm now on I'm not supposed to know the
history of this building and well this
is a post office but the state house and
um so my one of my very first meetings
uh the subject of liquor came up and
they said aren't you aren't they glad
that I'm here and so so uh what you're
going to learn now is uh uh a another
inside Department inside baseball type
issue of how the liquor committee helps
thank you yeah so I just saw I'm clear
we're talking about 248. 248 okay right
so yeah I believe the intent of this
bill is um as you all know we have our
commemorative bottles
um that come out and I believe the
intent of this bill is to allow the
legislative historical committee to use
that money for
um
for other responsibilities
um as you can see the the language here
that's deleted is
um
relative to directing funds towards the
preservation of the Hall of flags and
this would simply allow them to use that
money for for other instances
right the the problem was it was limited
to the hall of flags the fund was
already existing so we want to expand
broaden its capabilities correct because
it's kind of hard to put the Hall of
flags in a commemorative bottle that's
yeah
so
so any questions uh in terms of the
intent of this bill it's pretty
straightforward
to see none thank you very much
okay
chairman would you like us to stay up
here for 407 or why not
oh okay I have the gavel hasn't hit yet
okay
um the bottles themselves
um who who selects the designs who or
um I apologize I don't actually know the
answer to that
um but I can we can certainly get that
for you
um
that's more done by the commission side
in the Marketing Group so I'll have to
talk with them to see who actually is
the one that chooses those and Designs
those so yeah just make sure the
marketing is there when we do the
subcommittee okay okay I can definitely
do that because I we all want to know
where it really comes from
um well I was I was kind of hoping it
Sazerac right Tesseract should make it
yes but I don't think they do but I
don't think so we'll just email me okay
okay
uh
oh I see the cards you gave me were 407.
you didn't give me any cards on the on
the commemorative did you know we did
not
Horsemen you don't know anything about
commemorative bottles
what am I thinking we did the best we
could Deja Vu yeah
sure yeah okay
thank you chairman and committee members
uh the HB 407 uh is a bill that has six
parts to it and really it is just
addressing some of the
um inconsistencies that have developed
uh from other Law changes over the year
um I can bring you through each of the
sections uh they will move quite quickly
starting with Section number one
it inserts illegal into paragraph six to
read license sheet shall not allow
illegal gambling or wagering on their
license premises
licensees throughout the state are
currently authorized to conduct gambling
operations on their licensed premise
through New Hampshire Lottery Commission
so this just inserts the word illegal to
prohibit illegal gambling charitable
giving gambling
exactly the charitable gaming yeah
um section number two
is in reference to employment employment
of minors in felon exceptions
it removes language in paragraph four
pertaining to designated persons in
charge being required to complete an
affidavit and file the affidavit with a
commission in 2018 paragraphs five and
six were repealed from the statute
making it no longer a requirement for
employees to obtain a felon waiver
exception
the existing language requires an
employee to file an affidavit a testing
they have not been convicted of a felony
with no way to provide for an exception
this language is no longer required in
the statute since the intent of the 2018
change was to allow employees with
felony convictions to be employees
without exception
I will note too that the uh upon passage
of this bill the administrative's rules
will be updated to reflect those changes
pertains to 178 22 on-premises cocktail
lounge licenses licensees and this
simply removes duplic duplicative
language quote unquote and Lounge from
so is this rewriting of Q or that is Q
already in statue
Q's already in statute just striking out
the in Lodge twice written twice
how could
section number four
is in reference to RSA 178 26 additional
fees
and in paragraph one uh this bill
inserts the Nano Brewery license with
other manufacturers who produce
beverages relative to the fees at 30
cents a gallon of sales and penalties
for failure to pay those fees in
paragraph two it will insert the Nano
Brewery license with the other
manufacturers who produce beverages
relative to paying the fees on or before
the 10th day of the month covering sales
essentially it's creating parity with
the other manufacturers who produce
beverage
great
section number five has four statutes
included in Roman number two that get
repealed
that's it that's the in the existing
statute
it's already something it's already in
statute repealed already okay
section number five has four statutes
pertaining to this section in RSA 179 57
excuse me RSA 179.53 alterations of
premises repeals paragraph two as the
division now has specific license types
that combines one or more license types
and is most commonly used to provide for
an on sale restaurant license combined
with an off sale combination license on
the same premises that was the bill we
had last year
that's the combination conditional
license right that was the bill we had
last year yep good
RSA 179.57 suspension or revocation
administrative fines repeals paragraph
one subparagraph 1D again in 2018
legislation was passed in RSA 17923 to
repeal paragraphs five and six
pertaining to the felony waiver
exception for employees however RSA
17957 was not amended at that time
by leaving this language in the statute
technically prohibits a felon from being
an employee because the exception in
RSA 178
repeals paragraph five in reference to
the prohibition of sale of liquor and
beverages in the town of arrow with
exceptions pursuant to RSA pursuant to
RSA 541 a39 notification of
municipalities all municipalities are
contacted by the division to allow
reasonable opportunity to submit data
views and comments with respect to the
issuance of a permit license or an
action within its boundaries that
directly affects the municipality
based on this notification process
there's no need to have municipality
restrictions within title 13 statute
it's a Dry Town correct
they just don't want to have to keep
telling you why they want to be dry
to be quite honest I'm not sure when the
last time they were contacted to update
this information we do have licensees in
in Arrow
so oh you do yeah so it's not a Dry Town
anymore well this is only for it the
exceptions here are on the restrictions
for on-premises restaurants and the
restrictions
they have to be open
um at least five days a week right for
certain hours so yeah yeah I know the
hour of the requirements yeah complaints
about that exactly or days of the week
how many days a week okay
foreign
on premises beverage and liquor licenses
this repeals sub paragraph 2 A4 in
reference to the prohibition of sale of
liquor and beverages in the Townsend
Newington New Hampton and landaf with
exceptions pursuant to RSA 541a39 all
municipalities are contacted by the
division to allow reasonable opportunity
to submit data views and comments with
respect to the issuance of the permit
license or any action within its
boundaries that directly affects the
municipality so just like the prior
statute change this would apply for the
same you just said New Hampton I see
Newington Newington New Hampton and
oh okay
Newington
the current statute does happen you're
taking Hampton because they've
they now have a
off-premise licensee now
yes they all do the it this should read
foreign
so that's New Hampton right
Newington the way the statue currently
reads is the towns of Newington New
M okay
so a couple things for the committee
this is actually great to see how a
section of the bills these little
numbers there I remember for years I
couldn't figure out why those little
numbers were there and then it's because
it really is a separate section of the
bill and and it's a disconnect that each
one is a different RSA that are mending
so uh whenever you see a bill like this
where it has five or six sections now
you say oh my God this is a nightmare
because now I've got to take the statute
and figure out how where they fit into
the statue you know which we obviously
don't see uh when they're doing this so
that I remember doing that and that
actually believe it or not I actually
bought the rsas I used to get the rsas
this has been long before they were on
the computer and uh and then I
um so I could actually follow along
because in the old days I couldn't but
okay so we need an amendment for New
Hampton
any questions from the committee members
representing
polio
oh good
um number it's at the top uh line three
uh Roman numeral
um six licensees shall not allow illegal
gambling or wagering on their premises
can you expand on that I mean it's just
liquor licensees
he can't
so the way that the current statute
reads and thank you representative the
way the current statute reads is
licensees shall not allow gambling or
wagering on their premises
so
there's many licensees throughout the
state through New Hampshire lottery
commissioned or racing and charitable
gaming who issue issues those charitable
gaming licenses which is gambling
so gambling is a defined term in their
statutes and it puts it
this portion of the statute puts it in
direct conflict with
what they're issuing so by inserting the
word illegal of course that is legal
gambling this would just limit the
casinos in the state
yes there are but they're not casinos as
you would you know yeah yeah because no
they're charitable they're charitable
they're charitable they're terrible but
they are called some of them are called
casinos you definitely call them because
yes but they're all charitable gaming
that's how they're licensed through New
Hampshire Lottery
and they don't have slot machines or
I don't think they do actually well
there's a commercial that's coming soon
really do we allow that no
okay not yet I didn't think so I don't
think I I didn't think I don't know the
specific parameters of the charitable
gaming license I'm not sure that they're
actually called slot machines yeah
that's why they might look like yeah I
don't know the the oh I know they're the
historic horse racing but they're on
they're on the TV rather than you're
sharing it yeah but again it's something
that we allow now with the charitable
gaming
and just uh another question about
social clubs
Social Clubs they do gamble there
because they have this tickets do you
govern the tickets we do not that is all
done through the New Hampshire Lottery
Commission too but they are all licensed
to do that yes
and
um follow-up for the question one more
time
um
does the Liquor Commission
um investigate or just go into you know
Social Clubs like they do you know
restaurants or bars thank you for that
question representative and yes we do
the the premise inspections by our
investigators are conducted on all New
Hampshire licensees so thanks yes thank
you
this is a request for clarification
um looking at the specificity of the
language as I understand it the language
of the existing statute particularly in
regard to the operation of restaurants
and cocktail lounges
um my question is why is this level of
specificity in the statute at all why
isn't this left to administrative
regulation
thank you representative in in which
statute were you referring to on that
yeah
so I can actually answer this question
um
we only have restaurants
and that a restaurant as long as it's
serving food
actually has a cheaper license
than if they um
want to close the restaurant
and the rest and that that moment of
closing which is usually nine o'clock I
think is when the magic hour and then
they have a a space that they're going
to call the cocktail lounge
and so yes there is a this very
distinctive statute you can see in terms
of the operating three hours I've been
open this is all because we're now
articulating what makes it permissible
for that restaurant to stay open
without the restaurant staying open
because otherwise because now for all
intents and purposes it's a bar so
that's why we have this long statute and
the only reason I know all about this
was way back when when I did the um I
was chair of the subcommittee for the
smoking Act
and the indoor smoking act we were
basically changing the law in New
Hampshire from where you can just look
for non-smoking signs to now you only
can go where there are designated
smoking areas
and the hot spot was what we're going to
do about restaurants
and so we specifically I we came to this
found in a statute and I never really
this is long before I ever did any
liquor laws legislation where we came in
with the restaurant hospital by the way
there's this definition of a cocktail
lounge and that was Bingo that was where
we were going to allow smoking up until
um about 10 years later and that got
repealed
in terms of smoking in a cocktail lounge
so that's why
accept of your well social clubs are
different but so that's why this is so
particular in detail was to really
articulate what is that space that
um is is is is for all sense of purpose
it's a bar but it's a bar inside a
restaurant
yeah I guess I still have the question
this is uh subcommittee no you go ahead
go with your question
thank you
um why isn't that level of detail left
to administrative regulation by rules I
was in left to rules I sorry that's what
we call it rules yeah why wasn't it left
to rules yes yeah so um
you know I used to have a running joke I
said you know what I think all rules
should expire and we should then bring
them in and put them in the rsas so
people didn't have to go look at two
different places for all the laws of the
land
but what happens is is that the
legislature in its wisdom can create a
concept and create something
but that if we were to spend the time to
go through and there's a lot of words
here
so we were to go to through this and
create this all these words you would
say oh my God you know it'll take
forever it would take for it to pass
well it probably did take a long time
for this section to pass
rules
um for some committees rules are great
let's just do everything by rules
and other committees know we we want to
have a lot of Statute have a lot of
Statute
um I grant you this is a very long
rulemaking section but it was compelled
that uh to make this clear they I I
would say this didn't pass in the year
it took a while for them to get all
these words together and
um it is for both people who are who
have to read the laws that if I were a
liquor licensee it'd be nice to see
things in the statute rather than having
to go look at rules that's all no
particular reason thank you
okay
yes representative field
two questions related to the section
about uh persons in charge of the
premises okay the first is that uh We've
struck the language related to an
affidavit for the person in charge that
they're over 18 and not convicted of a
felony
but then at the end of the paragraph
there's added language that licenses
shall maintain a record of all
affidavits for persons in charge
so we created a contradiction there that
we no longer require an affidavit but
we're requiring an affidavit
thank you representative so there's
really essentially two
um
different scenarios where affidavits
were presented one was for persons in
charge and one was for ownership so the
ownership and felon exception waiver
process still exists in statute so we do
need that affidavit still
and that's what this affidavit is
referring to which uh is is why I
explained an administrative rule that's
where that's going to be cleaned up so
we intend on having a form to designate
the person in charge and the affidavit
will apply to the ownership for which
uh and as a clear part of the statute
are they the earlier part of the statute
uh we're on page one on line six through
13. we're on right now you're looking at
uh paragraph uh four paragraphs so we're
looking at now
so looking at the struck language in
lines six through eight as compared to
correct if I could clarify we are
um getting rid of the language that says
the person in charge has to have it at
the affidavit on file that attests to
their felony conviction
the request there's still a requirement
for them to designate a person in charge
but this language is specific to the
person in charge affidavit attesting to
their their criminal background that is
no longer needed because a waiver is no
longer applied for that so that language
removes the requirement of the affidavit
to speak about their their criminal
background it keeps the language in
there that um if you look a little
further that for the purposes of this
section any corporate officer member of
liability companies shall be deemed a
person in charge of the license premise
those corporate officers those members
of the limited liability companies are
persons in charge they're automatically
persons in charge they have other
requirements regarding their criminal
status so they have to apply an
affidavit so that is the affidavit that
they're speaking to here we're just
striking the language that says the
person in charge has to have affidavit
on file attesting to their criminal
history wouldn't it be better to say
records of all affidavits including
a felony conviction in other words
because it just says all affidavits it's
sort of they all affidavits are kind of
hanging out there
shouldn't you have some saying or you
know the records of all affidaves
including which is what the paragraph
and thank you chairman and I can see the
confusion that that may cause if you
would like we can work on language for
the subcommittee on that I think I was a
just to clarify because I you know all
affidavits how many other affidavits are
there
right we have a lot of paperwork it's
not about all of them it's about
affidavits related to felony correct
right not the word all so I would be
scratching the word all and that the
records of of any affidavits for
felonies
perfect we'll work on that thank you
and then one other question related to
the section uh you've struck the
language related to a person in charge
uh and a felony conviction but also in
that same area that struck uh struck the
requirement they'd be 18 years of age
and older well I'd imagine there's
elsewhere in the stature that requires
that the person uh not be a minor uh it
may seem a little awkward here to have
struck that specifically in this section
would it be desirable to still say that
a person in charge needs to be 18 years
of age or older and then also still
allow that person to be a corporate
officer
thank you representative I believe that
is covered in RSA 1783 and we'll we're
checking on that now
um but yes during the application
process that's where on all of our
applications which are governed by rule
those questions are asked on those
documents as well right I'm just saying
that perhaps for consistency sake we
should leave the the language here that
the person is required to be 18 years of
age or older particularly for creating
legislative history if we strike it here
but leave it elsewhere it creates an
ambiguity
yeah sometimes redundancy is okay
if if
it's a different thought I mean one
thought is you know that's that's the
ownership
but if this is about
correct if that were to remain then we
would have to still file an Affidavit of
testing that there are 18 years of age
correct which would be a very simple
affidavit but it's probably an important
didn't file
and presumably you don't want a minor
if you would like I can certainly uh
research that for the subcommittee in in
um
if needed we'll add that to the
amendment yeah just
I I mean almost
change what is the purpose of this
paragraph is this purpose of this
paragraph originally maybe was the
felony issue okay but now since the
family's been taken out so now the
purpose of this paragraph is affidavit
that that the person in charge
exactly we were trying
to limit the number of affidavits and
think of it in this context we have 62
60 to 6400 licensees in the state all of
whom
um are sending in multiple affidavits
per business so that's literally tens of
thousands of documents that are being
retained and since the felony exception
for the persons in charge has been
repealed
the thought was that there was no reason
to submit that affidavit anymore and
um
uh the I think the part that we're
missing here is this is a
um edit to paragraph one
further on in that statute section two
says a person at least 18 year years of
age shall be in attendance and be
designated a person in charge of the
employees and the business and then in
paragraph three it says the provisions
of this section shall in no way prohibit
an on-premise or off-premise licensee
from employing person's 18 year age or
older to sell server otherwise handle or
be left in charge of the business so
it's it's actually in the statute
further down twice
so what I want you to do is rewrite this
paragraph and turn it upside down
and bait this paragraph is about when do
we can definitely and that they must be
maintained and it must be maintained
perfect thank you
representative filo does that make sense
to you
I think that makes it that really what
you're trying to do is specify when and
affidavit is needed to uh eliminate the
burden on your behalf of how much
paperwork you're getting so really
you're actually creating more of an
exception to win an affidavit is needed
or not dated correct correct that's
correct so yeah I think it makes sense
to flip it over and say when when do you
not want to be bothered with the
paperwork
okay perfect thank you all right
all right any other questions uh for 407
so much for housekeeping thank you thank
that's it right
okay
okay so close of 407 okay so 304 the uh
sponsor which actually had a bill after
that and he told me he won and released
but he didn't realize that 304 was there
also so
um we are going to open the hearing in
304 and close the hearing because I know
there are a couple of people here here
for 304 and we will reschedule uh 304
yeah and I'm sure we all have used
okay
and so I will recess this Harry
okay so we are we have a very busy day
tomorrow
and
the 215 got canceled and um
and then because these last two were
representative Magoo's bills and
evidently he's in Toronto
um all right so uh just so you have a
picture for next week next week
um obviously Tuesday is a session day
where we're gonna hear from the governor
and the governor's budget
um and then it's a session so let's see
what bills get uh attended to
um if you guys all get your blurbs in to
me who else am I missing I guess I
uh looks like I have to do a couple okay
so then we'll have some of things on the
calendar but I think pretty much
everything we have was consent except
consumer protection
um
when is 6 45.
which ones
okay so yeah
okay now so so to
which
okay we are doing the Cannabis at was it
yeah I don't know do I I don't I don't
today
[Music]
does anybody have an actual house
calendar
oh it did have it today okay then it's
today
if it is in the calendar today it's in
somehow I thought I just did it
okay
all right I take it all back
no I
don't
yeah
uh this is the subcommittee this is the
liquor subcommittee
yeah
okay
I thought it was yours you can have it
if you want but yeah what Carrie sent
out okay that was today right I just
didn't have she didn't leave it with me
that's all because what happened was 215
was was his other bill
and that I deleted his bill and then I
stuck yeah
there it is yeah no I I now remember
everything I did okay so just so
everybody
um well next week
um Wednesday is a a D-Day where we got
to get everything done so I will be
after the hearing we have on Safeway
glass then we'll be doing subcommittees
on all the early bills
and then and then we'll exec them in the
afternoon and because they have to be
out
Wednesday well technically Thursday
and then Thursday I'll start scheduling
um uh
EES on the different divisions so I'll
probably do
one of them in the morning one in the
afternoon I haven't figured that out
which one I'll be doing
and I just want to stay on top of
everything we'll probably uh assuming
we're going to get enough done I'll try
to schedule another exact session
for the following week before we go on
vacation
and yes we will be going on vacation yes
we do
okay very well
okay
foreign
we'll open up the subcommittee
on 639
and
the opening of the conversation here and
that is evidently there was a fair
amount of mailings that went out to
uh well I don't know I don't I don't
remember seeing all these but I guess I
wasn't paying attention enough but uh uh
of people who were upset that that
things were taken out of uh in my
Amendment they were taken out of
6 30 the original bill that they would
like to see back in
so one of the issues was the
self-cultivation
all right self-cultivation is actually
another bill that's in Criminal Justice
okay so
um
uh so what else one of my next thing is
licensing
um
which may include so what so what are my
it's just a list of all the concerns
with the amendment okay so let's I guess
we'll go through this list here
all right personal Liberty and annulment
okay uh unlike the introduce the bill no
it does not allow secure home called I'm
explaining why I took home cultivation
out you know it's going to be addressed
in other bills so why why do we want to
address it in this bill
removes the robust enrollment and
resentencing Provisions for past
cannabis conviction again that's in
that's in uh criminal justice
Mr chairman
yes Ms Jared over here yeah sorry uh
yeah so just on just that logic not even
necessarily this point but it was kind
of I kind of equate that to the the Nano
Brewery where we were thinking yeah it
might be in another bill but what if
that bill doesn't pass and so if it's a
good piece
shouldn't we pass it and then if there's
another bill that passes something
similar then we can kind of deal with
them but we would would hate to exclude
something that we do think is important
because it's in another bill and then
that other bill passes and it's now
missing from okay so if you guys want to
into 639
um I guess I just need to know you know
if it basically if I take this all this
list of stuff here and go find it in in
the original 639
and stick it on the amendment
well I mean obviously do you but do you
believe me when I say that we don't
really want to muck up this bill with
with home
we're hearing you just want to pass 639
well look you can we can go two ways
with this one we can make a statement
about what a large Coalition of people
want and just watch it die
or we can pass something that we think
has a shot of being signed into law
on this home Grove piece in particular I
know that's a deal killer this bill will
not be signed into law with home grow on
it
um that's something I think we need to
go after in the future okay kind of like
uh on with hobby Brewing right you know
we didn't have hobby Brewing back in the
day but over the course of time we added
it I think one day in the future after
people see that you know the sky is not
falling and you know people aren't
running around
creating Carnage on the streets as we
heard in testimony that home grow is
going to be a much more viable uh thing
yes and I'll say the same thing for the
annulment piece as well
that's that's another one that's not
I mean do we really think that is going
to sign anything I mean didn't he say
he's just basically against any
marijuana bill am I wrong on that
uh let me put it this way I I don't
really spend a lot of time worrying
about what the governor is going or not
going to do right okay what I was uh
trying to do was
um
uh I I'm a big believer kiss
and to do a piece of legislation that is
um in in this case it's just as simple
as I could how could I shrink it down so
it's very straightforward and simple
um that it even in in the way this bill
you know what I did with the bill is
that you know I haven't put in a tax
structure I didn't put in you know eight
and a half percent tax what I did is
instead is is that the Liquor Commission
will have hearings
and once they have hired somebody who's
a little more of an expert on the market
and done a market analysis then we're
better able to decide what is the best
place for the fees for instance I I'm
more apt to say we should be uh charging
the fees or whatever Revenue to start it
at the cultivation level
that the cultivators when they ship the
product when they sell the product to
wherever they sell it to at that point
is where I think we should be getting
our cut much like we do with the beer
tax we charge it at the at the
production level
so um that but it you know in terms of
other states and that was the big thing
when so we was looking at what all these
other different states some of them have
a a myriad of tax you know Revenue
sources so they took they charged it all
all steps of the of the process so we
might want to do that but again that is
something I if if we get into start
putting specific things then you get
friends and enemies
on any one given issue so what I was
trying to do was try to keep it simple
and straightforward its Liquor
Commission is going to be doing hearings
process they have 16 months to go
through all these different hearing you
know process of what each level and as
representative Gibb says you know why
isn't this done by rule making well
that's what this uh my amendment was
attempting to do was to do it by rule
making each step of the way that there
would be plenty of input from the public
from these people who are all care so
much who want certain things they would
have that opportunity to express it so
if it's if some people say well you know
we don't like how you're giving up the
money in terms of towns and and Health
and Human Services they want to see it
to give into something else that should
be happen in a Health and Human Service
process if we really get down to going
through all the stuff that's in this
bill then this bill is not getting out
now we're going to be holding on to this
bill tonight Mr chair but isn't one of
the main issues that
from the folks who put this together not
having the Liquors commissioned oversee
this that it was going to be an
independent
they had an independent commission yeah
how did you come up with that Amendment
it took you you half an hour to come up
with that amendment that you were
proposing last time we met like who
helped you with that Amendment yes the
Liquor Commission I did go through it
with the Liquor Commission yes
yes I like to ask Mr Osborne
representative Osborne how you feel
about the Liquor Commission overseeing
it since you were a sponsor
look um
I I don't like it I don't like the
original bill I um in a co-sponsor of a
bill over in criminal justice that I
prefer that simply just eliminates the
statutory reference to marijuana but uh
that's you know I live in the real world
we gotta try to figure out what we can
actually get passed through the entire
process
um and like I said I'm I'm fine you know
I filed this bill on behalf of uh of a
coalition and I I will uh you know stand
by whatever you know everybody wants to
do
um so if everybody wants to just make
the statement about what you know our
Ideal World that we would like to live
in is uh I'm fine with that but if we
want to try to actually get something
passed into law The Liquor Commission is
the
path to get that done
so I'm not quite sure why you
other agents
agents that took them a year to like
weren't like were you a part of putting
together this bill or did you just put
your name on it
uh they came to me at the end of the the
process
so he has the answers yeah he put his
name on when they asked him
that's all I wanted was an answer that's
it
so are we
are we really I mean
I mean you you talk about you think this
could get through which is I mean it'd
be great if we get something through I
I'm definitely I definitely want that
but
obviously we have to go through what we
we want in there for sure whatever we
push through this committee but also
do we think that there's any reasonable
chance that this is going I mean if the
governor is going to veto it most likely
if we take him out his word then
I would say let's let's lean on a
statement of what the best build is we
can signal for next year or whenever in
the future that that's my thinking on it
but if somebody else has a different
view on it let me know I mean I think
let's put the best Bill we think we
would like to see and if we can't get
that then release because it sounds like
we're going to get nothing is my guess
if I'm wrong in that then you know right
tell me you think I'm wrong but if if we
actually think the chances of us passing
anything related to this topic are slim
to none then let's push through what we
think is is best to give a blueprint for
the next
the next session the next year then
whatever when maybe we have a more
favorable environment that that's my
view on it
I I I'm just I'm at a loss I feel like
this is like uh binge watching The Jerry
Springer Show I mean it just you know
one one episode after another another I
think it's been how many times six and
um I'd really like to figure out a way
that we could we could get something
through but
um
I don't know what the answer is I really
don't
well I think I had the answer that's the
whole point that I I I the signals the
hand signals that I was getting is from
when from the Senators
okay and I'm not talking about the
governor now
from the Senators
well Comfort level was
um was what we had you know originally
introduced you know last year which was
the idea that the Liquor Commission was
going to run it
obviously after thinking about it and
trying really hard to figure out a way
to make that work it's obvious that that
the the right way to do it is the way
the Liquor Commission Now enforces not
so much the liquor but how we enforce
the tobacco and that is we deal with
licensees and the licensees deal with
you know the the producers and the tax
um and you know I think I've no one's
ever complained to me or ever said
anything that the Liquor Commission does
a lousy job of regulating uh cigarettes
you know in terms of the taxing and
enforcement and and doing their stings
and making sure that young people don't
get you know sold so that that the idea
was that I realized that everybody had
um
there are lots of other issues I'm going
to listen to law enforcement and I
listened to you know in terms of these
different organizations who are looking
for monies and how to get the money or
or even the at you know the uh the the
medical marijuana atcs whatever they
call them so
my goal was to take out of the bill all
that stuff extraneous stuff
and keep it simple to that
that is a framework
to get this legislation passed
knowing full well that that yes it gives
a lot of power to the rulemaking process
at the you know the Liquor Commission
you know because they obviously they're
the ones who certainly have done plenty
of rulemaking and and when it comes to
either cigarettes or alcohol but they
have a process and he'll have plenty of
opportunity for public input in all
those steps to get there
and that when it comes to what is the
right taxation what is the right I mean
what is the right uh what is it
someone's complaining about how much THC
is in there you know all those things we
have written in this bill the way I've
written it it was that's going to go
through a rule making process and have
it processed and I and I just think that
that when it comes to people who have
been
um fearful of passing the marrow the
original marijuana bills is because
you're worried about this piece or that
piece or this affirmative value this
thing but when the end of the day's here
do you really want to pass it or not and
they said well I want to pass something
so the only way we can get moving
forward is to begin that process to
having hearing process to take those
different steps
but at the end of the day it's about
licensure and as much as I would love to
have
State Stores that's just not going to
happen
um but it you know it is to have
um as someone who an entity that's known
how to do this they do a good I think
they do a good job they bring in a hell
of a lot of money to the state because
their motivations are in the right place
how to maximize the profit and I realize
that I'm not going to please all the
people all the time but if there's you
know specific things in this list of
what they were looking at
um that you really think that needs to
be addressed or need to be solved rather
than waiting for rules then uh certainly
willing to discuss it but to pass that
bill in its current form
it's just it's got too many too many
words on it I guess of the way I would
call it well thought out I'd no doubt is
well thought out because they covered
everything but did I mean maybe I'm
wrong I thought that you had pulled that
Amendment that's what we had heard that
you pulled that Amendment what do you
mean by pulled that you pulled that you
were not putting it Forward anymore
that's not true
I I the the the the amendment I have in
front of you is is the amendment that I
want to go okay you do want to go
through okay that what the problem was
is I was misspoke speaking about what I
thought was in it okay because I had
this concept and it and it changed so
that and the the big change was that we
were not going to do the rfps for the
life you know who would be operating the
stores that we are going to have a
licensing and that um we will certainly
give guidelines for the zoning and let
in terms of towns and what you know what
they're going to do with zoning and they
will determine where or how many they
want in their Community
um in terms of so that so there really
is no limit to the amount of numbers of
them even though it says in the end that
the commission may limit to them so so
the commission will have a public
hearing
and get inputs from all anybody who
wants to input on what is the
appropriate whether we should limit
license or not or whether you know or or
what that is so that would done all by
public hearing and to be a public
process rather than for me to just pick
a number and pull out of my you know my
hat and just stick it in there
um you know it it it gives it
opportunity so that all these people
were all these issues that they have
they can certainly bring them but I
didn't want to I absolutely I'll have
I'm
we'll admit no I was taking out things
that were unrelated to how we were going
to structure a system to sell it in the
state and that is that like the
Homegrown you know I just said this you
know and and
like I say I once I found out it was in
already that bill is already exists you
know why why put it in this bill why we
don't you know I have the old saying we
don't want to create a Christmas tree
here we want to keep it simple and keep
the focused on what this bill what's the
bill is attempting to do
so all I ask is is uh read it read the
read that Amendment with that light that
you know what that is there something if
you see something in these where people
say we really need to create this issue
or put it in there you know uh
um you know
this is a big change do you think we
should um like have like a public
hearings exactly what I'm thinking this
isn't like a little Amendment this is
like yeah plus I think I think a lot of
the Republicans have not seen that
document
um delineating what what some of the
perceived problems are from that that
group that put the original Bill
together right I agree with Jared 100 I
I'd like to hear from the stakeholders
okay
but but they're going to be asking to
put some of these things back into the
building probably yeah so I what I'm
asking you is do you get you go through
and tell me which ones you think really
should be put back in the bill well
again I think I couldn't tell you for
sure the one that bothers me the most is
the idea that there could be anybody
saying that there should be a fixed
number and I know that you just
explained that that's not what you're it
actually it did it did it say that in
the bill I might when I read the
amendment it said the commission will
determine you know and that's what I'm
concerned about I I don't think that
there should be anybody determining I
think if somebody is qualified based on
whatever the rules are that are decided
at some point in the future it sounds
like to the rulemaking process so if
those rules are I don't know you can't
have a felony and you have to be
financially sound and you some other
regulation okay then you should get
approved I don't think I think we could
easily here's what I'm afraid of I think
we could easily end up in the New York
City taxi cab medallion situation where
we start off yep with money initial
rules and then next thing you know those
people are fighting tooth and nail never
to be 20. I I absolutely we want to
if you take that amendment I would we
could remove that line that rulemaking
line because it's in rule making
all over the state so now it's the bill
that you don't want to pass you're just
saying that the amendment that my
amendment has that where where does my
amendment has it creates cultivators
it creates manufacturers who then
process that cannabis and creates
retailers all theoretically could be
small businesses I don't understand why
you weren't the commission and how you
adjust what do you mean whatever I mean
it the committee to
it's the way we should proceed I think
we need to be representing the people
and not agencies and not the governor
I and I I'm again this is not about the
governor for me for me it's about
um this is what I do as a as a and
you've seen me over the years Paul
rabbit you know I I pull rabbits out of
that I take bills complicated issues and
I find a solution that we all can agree
on and so what I was doing is that that
I was taking a bill that had was chock
full of lots of stuff in it no doubt and
then we and we still have another bill
you know we still have two bills yep
okay and this one unfortunately has had
an early departure date so that's why I
was working from this
but
um if you guys you know if you're really
if you really want to pass it as in that
current form and then see it I don't
even think that one will make out of the
Senate okay so and then have it die and
then we still have the other bill and we
can just retain that and then we can
spend all summer you know wait all fall
getting people to buy into it and then
bring it up bring something out in in
January I just feel our committee today
is handicapped because I know some of
you haven't seen this I I presume
representative post you haven't seen
this document and representative for
Sally you
okay but you're allowed to to talk
during the students everybody can have
an opinion representative filio do you
have a comment
uh no no comment just listening to the
no opinion
I have plenty of opinions there's none
I'm going to state
well I just I wonder if you know we
could give people in this room an
opportunity to review all this and maybe
we come back with the stakeholders and
we hash out what we can live with and
what we can't live with
so who mailed it out whose email that's
from the um marijuana policy what what
would have been the email person who
says my name on the top yeah well
marijuana policy project
okay
uh
reject chairman Hunt's Amendment okay
okay so is there anybody here who wrote
These memos
nothing
you can cover your face does anybody
want to come up here and tell me what's
really missing from my amendment that
they want to see back in it
it just is atcs okay
so yes I took atcs out because they have
a law they have a structure that if the
atcs want to uh to be in this business
and and you know wanted to do it that
there there's nothing stopping them from
what's that
no the nonprofit I've killed that bill
multiple times I don't know about your
time
no no that's not not when I was chair
that was when I was I was in the
minority
really
I guess I guess I'm getting old in my
Village okay so I've always been about
against this non-profit side they you
know this is the thing that it gets me
when somebody makes a deal
well you make it I got a guy that one
guy you know in in Derry and he's
bitching about the five percent and he
wants to go to beer 30 and when I
explained to him that his forefather he
might have not been in the room his
Winery was in the business but all the
other guys in the wine business were
perfectly fine with the five percent so
to come back and say for us to change it
now was ridiculous so were you in the
room when they came up with that
non-profit did you agree to that were
okay so here's my attitude about them
my attitude is that if they want if we
do pass a marijuana legislation
if we do pass it
and they come in and said we want to
open up our own retail store
because I because I was ignoring the
atcs I was trying to keep them out of
okay
okay I I can certainly revise that
I can certainly revise that is it uh
um yeah but we could certainly look and
so you would you think that the ATC well
actually I would think it'd be great for
the atcs to become licensed
but that means HHS might not be happy
that they're not they're going to lose
no just take it started in their own
business yeah why wouldn't they want to
no no no no no
that because that's a policy decision
that is separate from this bill this
bill is about how do we allow legal
cannabis use
for recreational purposes they're not
okay here's what here's what I would
like to do when we take up this next
week
would you draw up an amendment for me
that you would like to see in what's
written in my Amendment how you would
like to see that corrected for your atcs
great good
okay I'm I'm certainly willing to look
asking one person to fix the bill
without getting input and I I'm not
comfortable with that well you it that
believe you me if we get to Wednesday
and all the stuff is no no good
then we can just retain the bill
I guess the issue is going to be whether
we go to the floor we or we retain it
yeah do you want it do you want to go to
the bill which clearly is
the the original bill as sponsored is is
got just as many enemies
against it do you really want to go with
that or do you want to hold off and do
something I'd like to hear what people
in the room want to do okay
to her anybody else want to offer up
what they think we should do
I think we need more time to really
digest this I think a public hearing for
more than just the amendment might be
needed to review it I need more time to
go over it and um I did read that I
think there were a couple of very valid
points on that email I think all of us
should have that in front of us so we
can evaluate it and really come at this
and do it properly I understand what was
trying to be done with the Amendments
um I
I'm not making an opinion one way or the
other I just think we need more time to
digest this properly I know it's a
speedy bill but I think there's a lot of
moving parts and dumbing it down is
never a bad idea but we need to be very
careful about what we're doing
good
this this one is an early bill but we
foreign
no you want to pass it
well I'd like to have another public
hearing on on all the changes or I don't
think we have time because the bill that
we have we don't have we don't have time
for if for 6 39 yeah
we don't have time
for the other five whatever's what's the
other one five
forty four five forty four we can
absolutely have another public hearing
on another on its own if we were to do
Amendment for that
but 639 has to be out of this committee
and just keep 639 uh in advance yes uh
first of all um we don't have to have a
public hearing for you to invite people
to speak correct that is true okay also
if if we do anything to that other bill
that adds money onto it it becomes an
early bill
right so it it has the same reporting
deadlines
so
so it's either past something next week
or hold it off until next year I will
point out to all of you that uh you know
next year is an election year maybe you
might want to have this vote
in an election year as opposed to first
year I don't know
anybody out in the audience want to come
in and sort of explain why we should
move forward with 639 in its current
form is anybody here for 639 in its
great
thank you for the opportunity Matt Simon
I work for Prime ATC formally of the
marijuana policy project and again I
don't speak for the whole Coalition I
will say first of all the idea of the
Liquor Commission being the regulator is
not my preference I don't think it was
any of our first choices that alone is
not something the Coalition views as a
deal breaker that's been confirmed via
email today all of us have said that
alone is not a deal breaker what we have
said is that if the if Liquor Commission
is going to be the regulator that there
needs to be more statutory guidance and
there needs to be some kind of
independent oversight and transparency
into the process having rules approved
by gel car is one step of that but we
think the independent advisory
commission that was in the original bill
should be retained that that would
provide the kind of transparency we're
talking about it's an awesome
responsibility and a one-time
opportunity to try to transition from a
Prohibition Market to a regulated market
we think it's really important to do
that in an atmosphere where people
understand what's going on and
understand in particular that cannabis
is not liquor that is a fundamentally
different product in many ways first of
all it's a Botanical product that goes
bad after a certain time so freshness
matters and consumers are interested in
some different things than a bottle on a
shelf there's another key difference
which is that
a lot of people enjoy alcohol but I've
never had somebody tell me you know what
my wife was really screwed up I didn't
know if I wanted to go on living until I
found Bourbon and bourbon really changed
my life and made me want to live again
and I feel I can be a better father to
my kids Etc blah blah blah I've never
heard that about alcohol I work at a
cannabis dispensary and I hear that from
patients on a regular basis so for that
reason I think the service we provide to
14 000 patients in the state is
incredibly important we don't treat them
like somebody who's here to buy a bottle
of bourbon we ask them what they know
about cannabis and we meet them where
they are if they know nothing we teach
them we're trying to help create a
culture of responsible use around this
product and we do not trust that simply
putting it into the liquor model is
going to achieve that result so we think
the therapeutic cannabis program is very
important I'd ask that you hear from the
Department of Health and and services
I guess that's what I'd say from the
coalition's perspective if this is a
policy conversation of how to do this in
a way that works under the WIC
commission will participate in that and
if it's rushing something that does not
give them oversight and transparency
then that's going to be much more
problematic
I'll also comment just From primeatc's
perspective on the the for-profit piece
we've actually been neutral on that
throughout primes never taken a position
one way or the other on that
but our position within the context of
transitioning to an adult use Market
this is a bill that is going to allow
for-profit businesses to come to New
Hampshire and make lots of money and in
that context to tell the atcs who have
for the last six years been complying
with every Rule and Regulation and have
resulted in no negative headlines no
problems that I've heard about to tell
them that they have to remain non-profit
while big companies are coming in and
operating on a for-profit basis we think
that's fundamentally unfair and and a
big problem if the amendment were to go
into effect is written we think that
would destroy the therapeutic cannabis
program it would incentivize the atcs to
create separate for-profit businesses
and pursue for-profit licenses they
would have no reason to continue serving
patients if they did so they would be
putting themselves into difficult
financial position and the state would
be selling tax-free cannabis so usually
what keeps a medical cannabis program
functioning and in every state that's
done this but one they have maintained a
therapeutic cannabis program that
continues to serve patients it's
important for a few reasons one is that
adult use
it's only 21 and older we have
registered patients who are under 21 so
somebody needs to continue serving them
[Music]
usually it's a tax-free situation for
registered patients whereas adult use
consumers have to pay the tax so that
incentivize patients to to remain
registered
and patients usually have access to a
broader range of products and potencies
than adult use consumers for example
Edibles are usually limited to five
milligrams per per unit in an adult use
Market patients often use much higher
Doses and have been using for much
longer period of time so they have
access to a broader range of products so
the education we provide to patients the
ongoing counseling we provide
the products we provide that will not be
viable in adult use market for example
suppositories are not something you're
going to see in an adult use Market but
we have those
um
so for a number of reasons we think the
therapeutic cannabis program is really
important and needs to be maintained and
we're happy to talk about all the rest
if we're talking about how to make good
policy
buddy
yes
thanks for uh speaking to us so you've
thought about this more than probably
the majority of us on this committee
anyways
as you see you need a few things were
there things in here that you think
should be a must-have that have been
omitted in the amendment and we're
talking about changing the amendment
what things do you think we should make
sure is not excluded or is now
you know retained from the original bill
yeah number one for me is we spent a lot
of time crafting a thoughtful
deliberative transition for the
therapeutic cannabis program in a way
that made sense for everybody that
wouldn't leave patients behind the atcs
were not asking for any special
treatment we just wanted a viable path
forward
so what we did in the original bill was
the atcs would be able to convert to
for-profit they would be able to get a
retail license there would be
requirements that they continue serving
patients that they not Jack up prices
that they continue to to do what they're
doing it would also expand access for
patients and opportunities for adult use
businesses because the adult use
businesses would be able to apply for a
therapeutic cannabis endorsement so if a
retailer wants to sell to patients
tax-free
they have to meet the standards that are
established by the Department of Health
and Human Services for the atcs and if
they choose to do that they can that's a
model borrowed from Washington state
that we thought made a lot of sense for
New Hampshire
and
if we don't expand access for patients
patients will only have seven
dispensaries that they can shop at but
adults will have potentially a much
larger number of stores so we want to
expand access for adults and patients we
want to expand business opportunities
for both the atcs and everybody else and
do it in a way that makes sense I think
the original Bill does that I'm not
entirely sure how that works with the
Liquor Commission I'd be interested in
hearing the Department of Health and
well the way I was treating it was that
you would just continue as you are now
nothing would change
if we continue as we are now and adult
use stores regulated by the state open
up and serve patients tax-free they will
be competing directly with us as
for-profits they have access to Capital
that we don't have they'll be able to
build massive cultivation facilities
they'll be able to poach our staff
members they'll be able to destroy us
and and so they will be able to sell
marijuana cheaper than you
uh I I believe they would if if they've
chosen that the whole point of the
non-profit was that you guys were never
that that you're going to keep your your
marijuana cheapest I believe the point
of the non-profit status was to make
legislators feel comfortable with the
original Bill a number of States
originally required dispensaries to be
non-profit I'm not aware of any that
still do uh what really happens in each
case each of the nonprofits had to seek
outside funding and interact with large
organizations just to be able to
complete their build out and and get
into business so
um
it's complicated but non-profit status
did not create the best opportunities
for this business and it's become clear
so
this is just a fairness issue for us and
uh the reality is a large company I'll
give you an example in Maine a very
large company has moved into Maine and
they're publicly funded and they have
very Deep Pockets so they're able to
sell 75 ounces of cannabis in an attempt
to put as many other businesses out of
out of business as they possibly can
so there are large companies there is
Big cannabis and they do want to come to
New Hampshire and
when I was working on this issue in
Vermont we often heard legislators frame
it as do we want to create the Budweiser
of cannabis or do we want to create the
heady topper of cannabis do we want
there to be small craft businesses that
are focused on quality that
live by New Hampshire values or do we
want to open it up to a bunch of big
companies to come in and run everything
I think that's an important fundamental
I I don't know how you control that
I mean I mean unless you want to say
that you can only do so much about a
business
that you're going to the legislation
would say you can only you have a
certain maximum amount of amount of
volume they can do yeah well that's a
policy choice so in Massachusetts each
business can have up to three licenses
of each type in Vermont they were so
interested in keeping big marijuana out
that they limited it to one license of
each type so a big company can have one
cultivation one manufacturing One retail
but you better make it a good retail
because it's the only only one you're
going to have they also set sizes for
the for the cultivation tiers and they
did not license any very large
cultivators they licensed a lot of small
cultivators and some medium-sized
cultivators
there will be no big cannabis in Vermont
until and I think this is a very
important Point too and I'm sorry I
didn't mention it until now
interstate commerce is going to change
this picture completely
and there have been a number of court
rulings in other states already that
suggest that these siled state-by-state
markets are likely to become a thing of
the past pretty soon
Congress probably isn't going to do
anything but a court May strike down
prohibitions on interstate commerce
which would mean that whoever gets to do
retail in New Hampshire is going to be
who makes the money cultivation of
cannabis in New Hampshire is not going
to be a very viable business after
New Hampshire retailers can order from
you know California and places like that
the Liquor Commission succeeds in its
liquor model because they're able to
create stores that have everything you
could possibly want at prices that are
competitive if not better than
everywhere else and
if everything has to come from New
Hampshire
that's only the first phase of the
market we don't know whether it'll be
one year three years or ten years but at
some point interstate commerce is going
to happen and if for example the atcs
can only be cultivators well that's
that's just not going to be a viable
business in the future in all likelihood
so
you just made a great case for us not to
do anything and wait until until the
Interstate Commerce Act
is is fixed and at that point then we
can open up our state liquor model and
make shitload of money
that's a policy choice I think we wrote
HP 639 with the idea that we wanted to
anticipate those potential changes and
set
all these businesses up and the state up
for potential success while also
minimizing any harms associated with
well how so how did you protect how did
we protect Public Safety in public
health yeah well by requiring
independent lab testing for products
that was in the draft we created it's
not actually in the introduced bill but
we think that's an absolute must add
there will be no confidence in the
testing regime if companies are allowed
to test their own cannabis and put
whatever numbers they want on the labels
um but the the original Bill include
statutory language directing the
Cannabis commission to come up with
rules that prioritize public health and
safety labeling not having products that
appeal to Children things like that
restricting advertising
um
there's quite a bit in in the original
Bill I know it is over 40 pages I'll
just point out the Illinois Bill that
legalized cannabis was 600 and some
pages the bill that implemented adult
use regulated markets in Vermont was
over 100 Pages I've actually never seen
a cannabis legalization bill as short as
HB 639 so I understand the preference
for shorter legislation but there are a
lot of moving Parts here and uh it's
okay to take one or two things out and
maybe address them in separate bills but
uh
there is a fairness issue as well not
just fairness the atcs if people are
going to be making millions of dollars
off of cannabis and yet there are still
Granite Staters walking around with
criminal records for possession
we'd love to see annulment included if
it can be
yes representative Sullivan um you're
talking about the independent testing
which I get the logic behind it I'm
curious do you or does anybody in this
room know who tests like when I buy a
bottle of beer sometimes it's you know
five percent alcohol sometimes it's nine
percent alcohol is that just the
manufacturer selling us or is there some
sort of process that is third party so
that we can because I don't know of
anybody not trusting what's it's not
tested it's just the manufacturer's
labeling so okay so thank you for the
question I think cannabis is different
in the sense that a lot of unregulated
Market cannabis is Tainted with
pesticides with fungicides with mold
with heavy metals uh so a regulated
market is the way to make that not
happen in a legal Market the atcs have
stringent testing requirements we have
to have all of our cannabis each batch
independently lab tested all of our
labels include not just the THC content
but all of the cannabinoids that show up
on the test get included the percentages
include all the terpenes which are the
flavor molecules in cannabis we do very
rigorous testing and we inform patients
about everything that's in in their
cannabis
another question yep for the question
um so
basically you're saying because right
now it's an illicit Market we need this
testing to give confidence to the people
in third party testing is is why you're
pushing for third-party testing versus
looking at the liquor model where people
will test their own yeah I just think
it's one of the most important reasons
to have a regulated market for cannabis
um no problem for me to add that into my
Amendment but uh very good evidently uh
yeah representative
Osborne
um so yeah we'd already talked about the
independent testing earlier today yeah
um but um we also talked about the
independent Advisory Board and uh I know
you're not a fan of that
what do you think the possibility of
bolting something like I heard two
things The Advisory Board and then a new
Commission
well yeah I mean that was there which
one is which the original bill was to
create a commission and an Advisory
board right that that I that was I was
really but in your model of handing it
over to the Liquor Commission instead
because there already exists they know
how to do business and whatnot right but
what about bolting on an independent
cannabis Advisory Board just to make
sure what is the purpose of The Advisory
Board well because the Liquor Commission
uh they they don't know anything about
cannabis right right well I see I
thought we we have the electric
commission is going to be hiring
somebody you know who knows where they
come from maybe Washington or Colorado
but or Oklahoma somebody who knows about
what's going on and then and would be
head of that division
but in terms of The Advisory Board I
guess I was really fuzzy on what are
they advising when it's the commission
that is the one is the actual operating
of the licenses but so I was trying
again I was trying to keep it simple but
go ahead so Matt if I could ask you what
would you say would be the difference
between having an independent Advisory
board about cannabis to The Liquor
Commission versus having the Liquor
Commission having a department within
its own agency where they hire cannabis
professionals
I think the value of an independent
Advisory Board is that it provides
public transparency and it allows
experts from a variety of different
perspectives to be at the table when
rules are being developed so somebody
with experience with expertise in public
health is asking those kinds of
questions and making sure that there's
there's scrutiny from that perspective
somebody from that cares about Public
Safety is there somebody who actually
knows the Cannabis industry is there
having all of this
having them look over the shoulders of
the Liquor Commission as they're
developing rules and making sure that it
is not a back room thing that somebody's
coming up with rules and then bringing
them into gel car and not anybody
knowing what they are
as I've said before it's a one-time
opportunity and a lot of people have a
lot of perspectives on how this should
go other states have made some good
choices and some bad choices and we
should always be striving to learn from
other states and try not to repeat
mistakes if they're avoidable but I mean
I don't know you skipped the step that
in the rules committee where I hear that
they ask for suggestions and proposals
and they take you know work those
through I the idea that there's back
room dealing with rulemaking you're the
first person who's ever said that to me
in all my years
interesting no one has ever said there
was a backroom deal when it came to
rulemaking I've never heard that I've
always heard about the public hearings
and the public process I did hear that
we don't make the lobbyists wear their
orange tag at rulemaking hearing so that
I did that I did here you didn't have to
wear that when you go to the room of
making but
okay well like I say all of this is
going to take time so yeah
representative Philip
it would seem that the the value of the
independent advisory committee or board
would be simply that advisory and
provide a central point for the industry
to provide advice that could then be
passed on to the commission it would be
efficiency I think of having one Central
repository where the industry could go
to then to provide its input to then be
passed on to the commission and provide
also that transparency it essentially
would be a public committee that could
then have that public record of the
entire industry providing that input
that could then be passed on right to
the commission it actually would provide
I think efficiency to the commission of
having a central repository of this
public testimony that could then be
passed on rather than getting that all
through noticing of rulemaking to the
atcs do they have an Advisory Board
no so I was part of
the rule making process for therapeutic
cannabis and uh
I will say that I had to show up at a
whole lot of in-person meetings
usually by myself sometimes with
somebody from the ACLU of New Hampshire
and we were the only two Patient
Advocates who remained involved
throughout that process and we took it
upon ourselves to always be in the room
when rules were being debated and
discussed and uh
there was an advisory Council that was
created to oversee that program but it
was still trying to figure out what was
going on so um
does this still exist now the advisory
Council no it was repealed and replaced
with a therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board so now we have a an
independent Board of medical
professionals primarily and one patient
who who provide the oversight that the
advisory Council used to have one of the
issues with the advisory council is that
many of the opponents of therapeutic
cannabis were then named of the advisory
Council so we had to fight some of the
same battles all over again
trying to get the bill implemented that
we'd had to fight to get the bill passed
okay so the reason we don't want one of
these advisory is because the governor
well they're spelled out in the bill and
and some of them are are left to the
governor
so the problem is who who gets appointed
that's the problem with these these
oversight well isn't isn't that
something that we can just deal with in
the bill
right not put them in right and they're
saying is that you know you know how
they get a point it's political that
that the appointment comes in so when it
was like the speaker of the house and
the Senate President they make
appointments
it's all spelled out in hb639 yeah
no in terms of the I was talking about
the ATC one
the ATC advisor The Advisory Council
that has since been repealed yes
I mean it was a representative from the
police Chiefs Association and a
representative of the Attorney General's
office and a representing yeah a number
of them were named and then there was
a patient representative who was to be
named by the governor but then the
governor named a patient that none of us
had ever heard of and never came to a
meeting
okay
so you know it's fine if people want to
pass 639
we can make some changes
how are you gonna make changes in one
week right yeah all right so we will uh
if you have suggestions that you want to
make to 639 changing 639 as is uh please
get it to the committee
and we will uh take him up one one by
question so it's still illegal federally
right so I'm not sure if this bill needs
to determine what the issues are between
the federal laws and the state laws and
how they would be
adjudicated
so the federal government has its laws
and the state of New Hampshire has its
laws New Hampshire law enforcement
enforces New Hampshire laws
99 percent of cannabis arrests are made
by state state and local police
enforcing state laws so if the federal
government wanted to send DEA agents to
New Hampshire and arrest all of us who
consume cannabis all of us that run the
atcs they
technically have the authority to done
that do that Congress has checked that
Authority by passing budget writers that
tell them not to spend money to
undermine State regulated cannabis
markets so so far they haven't I was
thinking more like Banking and you know
I don't know applying for federal jobs
things like that
with banking I'm pleased to report we've
had access to banking throughout the
atc's existence we've never had to
deal with cash the way some markets Out
West have
I don't know if that will be an issue
for adult use cannabis but the only
people who can fix it are the federal
government there's a bill called the
safe Banking Act that's been debated in
Congress for years and
they could certainly make it a lot
easier for financial institutions to do
business with with cannabis businesses
but as is in the Northeast the vast
majority of businesses do have limited
banking services now to be clear we
can't get loans we can't get business
the kinds of products are available to
most businesses are completely off
limits we can pay very high fees for
okay
would it make sense would it make sense
for you and and a couple of your
colleagues on the coalition to provide
us as quickly as possible with a list of
what you can live with and what you what
you can't live with in terms of the
amendment
I I can certainly provide what Prime ATC
thinks is important for the amendment I
don't know if the Coalition will agree
on a United set of things
we were United on a drafting process
and process of getting feedback on our
draft and now the Bill's been introduced
so we're we we each have slightly
different views and opinions on some of
the details I'm happy to get I'm happy
to try to facilitate a coherent response
from the Coalition if not get every
member to weigh in with what they think
so um
do you guys care much about the other
bill
leave five what is it five
five Forty Four
do you have any love love
hey any feelings towards that
because I'm thinking that what we'll do
is uh you guys want to pass 639 it's
current form or whatever amendments that
you can hammer out
we passed that out and then we have a
month through 5 44.
and try to address some of these issues
I in terms of I don't know where the
consensus is that is that uh I guess uh
I was saying that two is better than ten
one or none
or in terms of is it
to retain which one you want to retain
no we have to
I don't want to retain it
let's get it let's get a list of things
we can live with and do it let's just do
it right you know I don't want this to
go away no really right well then on it
next week and then then let the Senate
decide which one they like better
I don't care about the Senate I do well
yes we do we're in the house
no we know that the Senate is has their
knives out so we we so talk to all the
Senators I have talked to Senators yes
but notwithstanding this I'm trying to
be I'm trying to facilitate passage so
if there's a a interest that says that
yet their heart set on 679 because they
all work so hard on it and believe
believe in what's in it and you guys
have decided that you
believe in them yeah then I think we
should do a bill you're you know we have
to we we're it's a tight window
you get an amendment done and ready and
we'll vote on Wednesday uh and send it
to the house floor it still has to go to
finance or a second committee anyways I
think it's Finance
um and in the meantime then I can work
on the other bill
and have my Amendment and take what
those things that I I think are worth
working on and and uh people want to you
know think it's really important to know
what the tax structure is right away and
they don't want to have a hearings
process because they think they're
behind the scenes stuff going on in a
hearings process then we'll try to I'll
try to limit limit shrink some of those
down
hopefully be quickly
could we have a zoom or something just
to see what we agree on what's what kind
of process can we do well we don't need
Zoom I can I mean you we can schedule
I mean I would do is I would schedule
after if you want it they will have
should have it you could have it by
Tuesday so we could do after after
session
I'll put it on the schedule that after
session we'll have a subcommittee on 639
and hopefully we'll Hammer up some you
know what what you want to run with
and and but I will be frank that I'm I
still think I'm right that should that
this bill this bill is never going to
make it and and so therefore I'll that's
give the Senate a choice
I'm pro-choice so would you be able to
get us something before Tuesday next
Tuesday yeah yeah I certainly can from
from our perspective okay great thank
you
if we wanted to we could continue this
meeting to tomorrow the next day or any
other time correct
uh week this is a subcommittee so we
could schedule right away yeah so we
could we could get out there
um
you know the structure the structure is
you use well I guess what structure
which Bill are you working from what did
you want them
to be fixed working on that we want on
work on the original 639 in its current
form
well I assume all these things here are
in 639
yeah the original yeah so there's that's
okay
Simon and your amendment to see what we
can pull which but which Bill are you
working from which one as an unamended
original right so but you're asking
them to make changes to six or nine and
they don't have it I don't assume they
or with the
with the changes that we were just
discussing to make it
an easy path an easier pass for for uh
commission you know okay I think it's a
question of what changes
um his organization can live with
that yeah that would have been that
would have been with my Amendment you
didn't discuss with them your Amendment
so that's what I'm saying I'm a little
fuzzy in what we're doing because I just
heard a presentation to say that we like
639 as presented in its original format
but they're willing to make some
adjustment yeah he said he was willing
to compromise he said so you guys are
ready and rearing to make changes to the
bill as introduced
to consult with them
yeah
I gotcha okay I guess I didn't hear that
part yeah no okay I didn't hear this
okay
Mr chairman I've already spoken with a
number of other members of the Coalition
and have asked them similarly to provide
a list of their requirements within the
framework that you provided under the
liquor community so okay everybody is on
that page report okay so uh we want to
schedule this uh I I guess we're free
Thursday
do people want to come in on Thursday
all right we're already here so what
time what's the what's anybody has the
no Keith yeah that'll be quick the
crypto it'll be quick okay so uh we'll
schedule it we'll schedule it for 2 45
we'll recess till 2 45 till tomorrow or
yeah excuse me
tomorrow
and in which case
we'll hope to have uh taking
from the amendment taking uh making the
or excuse me from the original 649
you'll take in the qualities of the
amendment into that is that the
versus the other way around what do you
think Jason yes I think everyone
understands we're trying to work within
the framework of the Liquor Commission
but we want to get all the results that
we initially intended I've already
talked with multiple people about the
issues of Home growing annulment in
particular that those are non-starters
but they're they're very concerned
around
um what Matt was just talking about the
the independent testing what was the
thing Advisory board and the um and just
the the whole the flavor of the thing
where we're just giving so much uh
authority over the Liquor Commission
without
any guidelines when we when we already
have a bipartisan uh effort right now to
try to range that in uh fortunately
Liquor Commission is being very well
behaved at the moment some of these
other agencies not not so much but
okay so all right do you is it is your
everybody's charge clear then
uh so are you okay
Mr chairman
um
Mr chairman are you asking that they
submit
um their proposed changes by tomorrow or
okay so we'll start with the HHS what
what is your concerns
you have to come up to the mic sorry
we might need it tomorrow
hello everybody my name is Michael Holt
I'm the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program within the Department
of Health and Human Services Division of
Public Health Services
um my concerns are that I'm I've not
been able to follow the uh where we've
landed
um uh and so I'm not sure which which
bill was being amended in what way so
that was my that I just have a general
concern about not knowing the direction
that's being uh that's being followed
here
um
639 is a thoughtful Coalition develop
bill that is uh is uh creates a soft
Landing for the atcs has social justice
Provisions in it regarding annulment has
an independent Advisory Board
um has some has quite quite a bit of
um pays quite a bit of attention to
public health issues
so
639 is is generally a a good bill it's a
good framework to to work on
um the regulatory challenge I think is
creating a new agency a cannabis
commission out of whole cloth so what
I'm hearing in this room is that the the
there are people that want to give this
responsibility not to a new commission
but to The Liquor Commission to run I'd
be interested in seeing a bill that
replaces cannabis Commission
in 639 with Liquor Commission and leaves
everything else the same yeah and what
is what does that bill look like
um I I I'm not aware of what are
non-staughters and what are not
non-starters and I'm not saying that we
you know you know HHS doesn't support or
oppose legalization at this point we're
neutral on it my interest is in the
viability of maintaining
um the therapeutic cannabis program the
atcs and 639 has that structure in place
that
um that
that possibly does that
um 544 does not
um and the amendment that we've that we
that we've been discussing does not
in in my opinion
one option would be to
pursue both bills
your Amendment representative hunt to
544 right
on its own merits and see which one you
know gets more traction in the house and
then to the Senate and then with the
governor
is there a way to make 639 more
palatable to all those interests
would that method be to replace
cannabis commission a brand new agency
with Liquor Commission
Maybe
um but we haven't we haven't had that
conversation you know what we have what
we've had is you know let's get rid of
all the good work in 639 let's replace
it with a clone of 544.
um
it doesn't make sense to me that we
would use 639 as a uh as as a Liquor
Commission Bill we should make forty
five Forty Four The Liquor Commission
bill you know okay and have them both
have them both you know parallel tracks
see what gets most traction the the only
compromise that I can see if we only
want one bill is what does 639 look like
as is
with Liquor Commission running it
okay so that that's our goal is my my
understanding that was the goal that
we're going to try to change 639 to at
least have the enforcement mechanism uh
being The Liquor Commission
is that agreed is everybody does anybody
disagree if somebody disagreed check
their head like this
okay all right so I don't see anybody
shaking their heads and then uh that has
to be out of the committee so we don't
even have to worry about 544 until the
dust is settled once we where we're at
when we take up 639 on the house floor
okay
all right so where direction is clearer
yes now you're happy right now you're no
I'm not I'm not happy I I'm not sure
that the Liquor Commission is the best
agency to be doing this right um but I
also you know as a regulator you know
with with Health and Human Services you
know yeah it would be a challenge to
create a brand new agency out of whole
cloth and expect that this work is going
to get done within the time frames
contained within 6 6 39 right you know
so I I see that as a at a place of
compromise
um is it the best you know is it the
best landing place I don't know that
um so I
I'm happy with the clarity you know is
everybody clear everybody happy yes
yes okay
yo yes
thank you very much you have somebody
are you still a foot doctor you still do
all right thank you uh johannan former
Commerce person I guess
um I um I was part of the Coalition I'm
not speaking for the Coalition uh I was
also one of the people on the uh
cannabis marijuana study commission back
in 2018 that was the last large
commission to study it uh another member
of our Coalition is also was also on
that and he and I Paul too and I were
people that researched all the
scientific literature to contribute to
that study uh we talked to people back
and this is what five six years ago we
talked to people from everywhere that
had legalized already and had tons of
meetings with people about how to do it
there wasn't a single person that left
that commission thinking that the Laker
commission was the best option and I
even asked the liquor commissioner at
the time I think was chairman Malika and
some enforcement people that were there
I commended them on making such a great
amount of money for the State of New
Hampshire they've made at that point I
think it was three and a half almost 3.7
billion dollars in 85 years for us
um and uh they're one of the largest
retailers in the country I think they're
one of the top 10 largest retailers in
the U.S for for alcohol
I thought that was great and I said so
if we want to sell as much cannabis as
possible we should put it in the state
stores or have the Liquor Commission be
in charge of it and they were like you
know not actually the the goal uh
interestingly enough a few years ago
chairman Malika said uh I don't remember
where he said it but I can find out if
you need to know
our goal is to revitalize the brand the
way you recognize Disney McDonald's or
Walmart we want people to recognize us
so if we put a cannabis leaf on the
liquor commission's web on their brand
how drastically is that going to change
the liquor commission's brand uh is that
the brand that New Hampshire actually
wants to to have you know we've had
prohibition of cannabis for so many
years and now we're going to legalize it
but the state's going to get most of the
benefits the state will get benefits if
there are other retailers the free
market can provide I think better than
even the state can in that regard the
liquor commissions and I know the
chairman is a big fan of the Liquor
Commission model and we've had these
discussions when I was here about who
whose responsibility this should be in
the beginning of probe after prohibition
was repealed liquor commissions were
instituted in States
uh basically to discourage the purchases
of alcoholic beverages by making it
inconvenient as expensive as possible it
wasn't so that we can get as much out
there and make as much money for New
Hampshire as possible it was to decrease
availability
so we're going to put and and that was
the goal at the time I can talk about
Virginia the governor actually said we
have to do something about it
um you know it was considered a new
weapon against this age-old evil it's
become a big business even in New
Hampshire that is not the goal anymore
there is a good regulatory system in
place I heard chairman give a speech at
the opening of a liquor store in Epping
when I was a State Rep it was about a
responsible product for adult use and to
you know all these different wonderful
things if you replace the word cannabis
for alcohol for cannabis it would have
been the same speech I think legalizing
it we all agree is the right option but
who should be doing that the person
that's going to be responsible for
selling as much as possible or leave it
to the free market and let people
actually decide what they want where
they want and how it's going to happen
we can still have a cannabis control
board having these uh discussions about
you know selling to minors and
advertising things like that similar to
what the lyric commission does but
um you know and like other people have
said I'm not against it if that's the
the deal breaker if it's only going to
pass with the Liquor Commission uh being
in charge of it I can get behind that
but I don't think it's the preferred
method uh for reasons I explained I mean
if we want to sell as much as possible
and make it our state brand
um you know is that what we want to be
known for as chairman Malika said like
McDonald's or Walmart is you know New
Hampshire alcohol and cannabis go for it
um but I think there was another option
I believe we should pass both bills
through the house and see what happens
if they both get to the Senate let them
decide instead of worrying about what
the Senate's going to do pass both
options that's my personal opinion
um
anyway
I'd be happy to take questions I notice
that hearing and taking me to go yeah
thanks
okay
remember we're not taking testimony here
we're just here talking about the
yes
sorry Kate frying the vice president
advocacy at new features I just want to
be really clear we don't we're not
picking with which side as far as who
regulates it that's up to the
legislature to decide we are looking at
it totally as a public health approach
to this so whatever model uh this
committee um chooses to go forward with
we have to ensure that there's
protections for Children and Youth
promoting social justice opportunities
and Equity protecting public health and
population health and ensuring that the
funding from Cannabis Revenue goes to
direct to reduce harms so there's some
of that in 6 30 uh 639 it doesn't go far
enough there's some of that in the
amendment I think that you had at one
point that doesn't go far enough and
there's some of that in HB 544 I can
provide you the language that meets all
of these principles and in the meantime
I believe I passed this out in the
committee but just so you have it it has
our principles what what's in the bill
and what the resolution is to meet those
principles I think that's a great thing
to pass out
okay since uh I get to have the last
word the only thing I would like to
room temperature change or whatever but
um my name is Heather Marie Brown I am
the patient representative on the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board
um so although the medical oversight
board didn't necessarily take a position
as far as whether we would support any
specific legalization Bill
what we did decide is that we're not
okay with any bill that's going to
jeopardize the therapeutic cannabis
program for our patients
um you know I think representative hunt
you did an absolutely wonderful job with
your amendment I would dare say that you
should probably have just submitted that
has a entire bill on its own it's that
in depth as far as being the largest
Amendment I've ever seen thanks but
um
I I do not I think that's an important
aspect is unfortunately your Amendment
doesn't include that it doesn't protect
the therapeutic cannabis program it
doesn't protect the patients uh if our
atcs go out of business then our
patients have no place to go where they
can receive the education the guidance
and the safety and the quality and
everything else that comes along with
being part of the program so I just ask
that the group remember that in the back
of their minds as they're going through
and picking and choosing and piecing and
gluing and you know hopefully that that
is made to be a important factor moving
forward no matter how you choose to
decide to move forward
okay thank you very much
okay so as I was saying since I get to
have the last word
um the only thing I would urge everyone
to keep in their minds
is that the Liquor Commission has
another task
and yes I did write the the law I wasn't
it was done a scitex uh bill but I'm the
one who fixed it it amended it and got
it passed uh and that is that it also
does tobacco
and if you look at the model that I did
it is very much like our tobacco stature
so uh as much as you want to throw
liquor and say this marijuana has
nothing to do with liquor I want you to
reread that Amendment and think tobacco
and what's the difference between
tobacco and marijuana I guess maybe
tobacco is not fresh I don't know it's
uh but um I I just want everybody to
know that when I was working this model
it was how in the new the new model now
as it's as as you see it is it's the
Liquor Commission is not doing anything
different than what it does now for
tobacco and even Kate knows that and she
doesn't like cigarettes
oh the indoor smoking part yes right no
I I still think restaurants should be
able to have smoking if they want to but
but I'm pro-choice okay with that we
will adjourn and we'll be see you all
so we're in the house tomorrow yeah 10.
in the morning
oh wait do we have a yes
yeah I'll be there
yes we're on our own committee room
tomorrow
because otherwise I have to write it
myself
technology